doo-doo-doo-doo and four three two yes
Spielberg who are you fella what's going
on see ya good to see you too thank you
very much for taking me up on that
flight I'm gonna tell you what
no legitimately you changed the way I
think about LA it's really small isn't
it it's way smaller than you think
yeah it's a different thing when you fly
over it you go oh do think that baby
yeah that's here this is that cuz what
if it I remember when I was still
getting my license and I was doing a
night flight right mom which is insane
totally different ballgame
and uh yeah cuz when you're on the
ground you like Wow be really easy to
see everybody because you're looking up
and all you've seen is the backdrop is
of the dark sky right but when you get
up there if someone's below you they
disappear into the city so that's what
yeah yeah yeah yeah so anyway so we were
flying back and I trained down in Long
Beach so we were going along the 710 and
I just see like all these these lights
and it was like right down like going up
like was and I go what's that he goes
and I got a pilot over goes oh that's
the that's the fireworks from Disneyland
and I was like [ __ ] Disneyland is
right there because in my head it took
like two hours to get there hour and a
half going down the five but it's just
like because you don't look at miles all
you do is look at time when you're
around here because there's so much
traffic but it's literally like oh
that's like 40 miles it's not even it's
like from Hollywood like I would think
it can't even be more than 15 20 miles
away like Anaheim is so [ __ ] close
but I just it's just hurt that you're
Irvine comedy club that's all I think of
it's just [ __ ] way the [ __ ] down
there and then you get up in a
helicopter and you're like they're in
like 11 minutes going like this is this
is ridiculous so yeah yeah that's
awesome dude it was awesome yeah it was
when you landed on top of that little
hill there with a picnic table
yeah dude this morning I said it down
nice I was little nervous oh my god
don't smoke don't [ __ ] this up with joe
here cuz he's gonna be like a burro you
know it's alright when he was flying
when he was the big part when he went to
land he wasn't that good but I was
smooth and then the Apocalypse Now [ __ ]
we're going through the canyon
that was awesome man yeah those are I
get it
those are fun that's it's a it's a lot
of fun and you know I fly mostly with an
instructor cuz I got the kid and
everything but every once in a while you
got to go up by yourself just so you
know you can do it but I also I'm
actually over to over do to do it but I
always go out and I do like the auto
rotations and he'll just sort of cut I'm
flying along he'll just chop throttle
and like it's just it's just rolling the
RPMs I mean rolling the engine now not
the RPMs the engine down and then you
immediately have to pick a spot you know
and sometimes you know the lower you are
you know it becomes literally what you
the first place you look is where you're
putting it it's really crazy but when
you would what you're talking about you
mean
crash landing that's what autorotation
means yeah it'd be basically if you had
some sort of failure problem your engine
failure whatever so like when you're
flying along the engines working it's
drawing air into the disc and that's
what creates lift but when when you go
into an auto rotation it's it's the air
rushing you're using gravity bringing
the the helicopter down using that air
like almost like a fan to keep it going
no so and there's a critical point where
if you let the main rotor go too slow
that's why the low rpm horn comes on
which is just a nauseating sound if you
let it go too low that when it gets to a
point where if it's spinning too slowly
no matter how fast you drop you can't
get it going again fast enough to create
and you're basically at that point
you're in something that's no longer
able to fly you're your instructor
Skyler so yeah
Skyler pointed out something I didn't
know that they have to redo those things
like every X amount of miles they
rebuild every hours yeah yeah it's well
they have like there's all this
maintenance along the way they're
incredibly maintained because I'm sure
you noticed if you read the comments all
people talk about is dying in aviation
it's like uh that's how entertainers die
it's like no it isn't they overdose if
you really look at the graph there on
the ground completely safe overdose car
accidents there's always overdose
drinking yeah and [ __ ] like that and
it's just like that's mainly how you die
like the amount of people that are up
there every day and the nothing happens
it's it's you know but there
you know the the fly in the ointment is
that this there are particularly at the
private level there are knuckleheads out
there like there's people like I think
every time I get in I'm always thinking
like am I gonna you know I don't want to
die today so I go over all about a whole
bunch of [ __ ] and you know especially if
I want to fly solo I have the whole
flight I have all my options on you know
where I could land you know if I had a
problem like that's what you're supposed
to do I look at weather reports I do all
of that [ __ ] and what happens is guys
get more and more confident and their
pre-flight is they kind of look it looks
pretty clear and then they go out there
and you know this you know this there's
people who go up knowing that they can
die and then there's other people up
there who just like magnum p.i and they
want to fly by waterfalls and [ __ ] I
mean those guys have more fun but it's
you know there's definitely those are
the people that you know you're supposed
to fly there's like two envelopes you're
supposed to fly within the envelope of
what you're flying and then you know
your skill set so you don't fly in this
[ __ ] this like you know like if it's too
windy or whatever I'm just I'm just not
going right even if I could handle it
it's like I'm not gonna have fun up
there [ __ ] you know riding it out and
just you know let the wind do what it
wants to do and don't fight it and you
know make sure you know you're not
flying to fail all you do is slow down
you know but you know it's it's that
there are elements of that but like if
you look up there versus what's going on
down below when you fly I always say
this when you drive on the highway it's
like you're flying in formation you're
in the Blue Angels yeah with a bunt with
nobody talking to anybody you have no
idea what anybody's gonna do people are
texting they're on medication they're
[ __ ] hungover they're suicide what
the [ __ ] they're doing you know and then
the top of that you got to look out for
the guys splitting lanes and the
motorcycles and [ __ ] it's pretty amazing
how few accidents are actually are there
it is it is and what I fly the Robinsons
they get a bad rap saying they're not
safe because they look at the amount of
crashes that they've had but it's
because it's a helicopter you can afford
so it's inherently a low our pilot and
if you look at it it's most of the time
it's not it's not the
it's the it's the person flying it which
is why you really have to be on it like
you you you can't it's it's just not
something I don't know how explain it
it's this weird thing where your your
level of enjoyment is way higher if
you're if you're riding in it you know
if you're the person flying the whole
time you have your life and other
people's life's at hand so that you're
not really oh look at that oh look at
that look at that yeah I'm also like you
know thinking things of like you know
when we were flying through that Canyon
Union you thought that at that I think
in that [ __ ] I'm looking you know
knowing where the wires are and where
the road is because that's all [ __ ]
trees so it's gonna be the road so
there's those you know when you're kind
of going around a bend you know it
there's certain like altitudes and stuff
just it's it's boring but it's just
stuff that you're always thinking that
you know I imagine like when you fight
there's that you know I know a lot of
it's like instinct and stuff but this
these things that you just don't do you
know what I mean I don't know anything
about fighting I was hurt in boxing you
know lead with an uppercut it's just
it's just [ __ ] things mm-hmm you
don't you see a lot of guys like when
they go to take off they do this [ __ ]
thing like the nose down attitude like I
was taught not to do that because I they
do that cuz it looks cool I don't know
why they do it I mean you're supposed to
look I was taught you're supposed to
keep it level so that way if you have a
problem you know you you're already in
you the right attitude to just
immediately enter enter an auto like now
if I'm [ __ ] nose down and if I'm too
far to the ground I was gonna [ __ ] go
right into the ground I don't know but I
mean I'm still like totally a novice I'm
coming up on 200 hours so I don't know a
lot but I'm super super super super
[ __ ] cautious and I make sure I don't
go too long without doing auto rotations
I used to hate them
and now I actually really liked them it
was sort of the way it was explained to
me I didn't get it until one day I just
thought about it and then I got it and I
was able to lock into it because it's
but it's the same inputs if you were
going in for a landing but they broke it
down to like four steps like it was low
rpm you know lower collective gentle F
cyclic
you know look at your trim strings you
know it was a trim state trim airspeed
rpms and just [ __ ] doing all
this and the reality is just like it's
the on right pedal Jesus Christ I forgot
that right pedal so it's all the same
it's all the same input if you were
going in for a landing
so all I do anytime I'm here the low rpm
is I just do that and then I'm locked
into it and then I'm just watching my
then I can just watch my rpms and at
this point I've flown enough where I
kind of know where I'm in trim which
basically means you're not like crabbing
and you're kind of going straight and
then you can kind of like pick out your
spot and then it becomes fun is what's
cool is you can do like 180 autos you
can turn around and what I do like about
it is when you come down to the ground
as you can bleed off all of your
airspeed that forward motion that's
gonna [ __ ] kill you and as long as
you don't [ __ ] up and flare and go back
up and then drop like it you know you
know it's kind of like a hockey stop as
the way it was described to me just
level it out and right as you go to drop
you pull like that and these guys land
on like daisies and stuff it's it's
really amazing I'm not as good as that
but like I will do it where you know
worst case scenario you know I might
[ __ ] like get a little bit of a bomb
yeah but I'm gonna be alright so yeah I
don't know now there's probably a bunch
of people saying I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about which admittedly
you know I still think there's a lot of
[ __ ] I need to learn about stand-up so
as long as you go into things like that
you know well the the fact that you're
doing it and the fact you learning a new
thing that's really difficult to learn
don't you think that that's good for
your brain no I am a big believer in
constantly learning it's why I like you
as a person because you're constantly
like you're not the Joe I knew three
years ago in a good way
you're like you you learn all of this
you know I first met you you weren't
hunting you were into Marsh that was
thinking you would you a two dimensional
you were which was amazing because
everyone was just a community with this
Taekwondo champion stand-up guy and then
and then since then you've added all
like the guests that you have on the
fact that you're able to like talk to
him when stuff is because you've
continued to you know you know it's it's
the same thing with like a comic who
writes his first hour and then just sits
on it for like eight years
yeah and all of a sudden two presidents
goes by and it's like why aren't they
laughing anymore it's like because
you're just stuck in time so III yeah I
believe in that I also believe in
playing cards
card games and stuff is good for you and
in any games if they say yeah video
games you know people like the [ __ ] on
video games but they say video games
have a positive cognitive effect on kids
yeah this is calculating and move it
you're thinking fast yeah they're
hand-eye coordination is like insane
yeah I guess if you some of those games
if if you play them I guess I don't know
well that you think about the amount of
hours they're putting into their thumbs
just how often do you really use your
thumb and like detailed ways very rarely
but kids today ridiculous thumb
dexterity I tapped out Grand Theft Auto
3 is when I stop which is about 2003
2002 or something I just think they were
just too amazing and I was just like I
am nowhere in my career right now and
this is just dude I was walking around
living in New York at the time and I
would stop playing the game and I would
be walking down the street thinking
about it like what I could walk into the
subway you know like not thinking about
jokes thinking how I could beat this
next level I remember I played this
medal of honor game and they had this
thing when you hit the sniper button
like the scope would go like that and
Exce would go like that and I played it
one day a 1-week so much that when I
walked out on the street I was looking
at people across the street doing like
their that X just like there's something
about like I already I'm not the
brightest guy you know when it comes to
like school and [ __ ] so it's just like I
was like this is doing something to my
brain so I kind of remember came home
and I just unplugged everything but
really quickly took everything off
because I knew I was never gonna figure
it out and I didn't have any
instructions anymore I just stuck it in
the back like well that's it I did the
same thing with video games with quake I
had a real problem when I was playing
eight hours a day ten hours a day
sometimes I had a t1 line installed in
my house just so I could play with a
fast internet connection this is like
1998 yeah this is crazy I mean there was
slow internet where I was so I said well
what's the options and so one option is
they chew up the street and put this
[ __ ] crazy fat business line cost me
a shitload of money and I was like let's
do it so it stalled a [ __ ] business
line that would use at the time you'd
use for a large building right and I had
it just for my my house and
I would play video games online all the
time and you could play online against
people for the last 20 years
oh yeah I didn't know that we play
online teams we'd have teams of guys
like like me and three of my friends
would play against four other guys and
we'd like meet at a certain server and
you know you could chat talk to each
other all right you ready to go all
right let's go three two one go and then
you know what the game will start and
then we we'd [ __ ] have these matches
and it was fun man it was really fun it
was really exciting too because it's all
happening in real time yeah but I
reached a point somewhere around like
the year 2000 where I know one day I
played until it was sunlight until the
Sun came up and you know I'm [ __ ]
thirty years old
yeah and I'm sitting there my hands are
sweating I'm all [ __ ] caffeinated up
I've been drinking Mountain Dew for the
past eight hours and I realized like
what am i doing like this is I you know
I'm not where I want to be as a comic
I'm not wearing where I want to be with
my life and I'm just sitting here
playing video games all the time and
there's no future in this because I've
been stuck in things where there's no
future before I know what that is I felt
like that with fighting I was when I was
21 there was a point in time where I was
like there's no future in this I'm just
gonna keep getting hit in the head and
I'm gonna get dumber and more brain
damaged and more crazy I'm like this is
dangerous and I realized I am I gonna
stop I gotta stop there's no fear in
this there was no money and fighting
back then either
and then I got there with pool same
thing with pool like my manager called
me up and he said I think you play pool
too much he's like he's like I think
that you seriously think about pool more
than you do your career and I respect
him and he's a very good friend of mine
so I had a really really Paul I didn't
you know I didn't take it lightly I had
to take a deep breath and I was like
[ __ ] he's right right I play pool all
the time was playing every day I have I
have a real addictive person - I do - so
I get like like how many hours I want to
get flying and then like things I want
to learn playing drums and stuff and
then it becomes I I've had to learn to
be like built these are hobbies yes yes
okay dad first and you're a comedian
let's go to
priority the world isn't waiting for you
to know how to play good times bad times
yeah that can sit back a little bit but
the fact that you're doing that kind of
stuff I think is great I loved I really
identify with you in a lot of ways when
you do that well you get [ __ ] crazy
about drums are you crazy booking up
yeah everything I just [ __ ] I just I
go down like I got to learn all about
lay yeah everything came out here I got
into old cars and then all of a sudden I
was watching this guy eric the car guy i
found him most fascinating because he
would work on like cars of today will
you just open the hood it's like what is
everything and where the how do you get
it and he's just taking off all this
plastic [ __ ] and just digging all the
way down and he's just like you know if
you can't remember just videotape it
just remember how it all goes together
dude one time he I forget what the hell
he was changing but he had to take the
whole [ __ ] front end of this car off
to change something that I used to be
able to change unlike my [ __ ] 83 Ford
Ranger I know that guy I know what
you're talking about
yeah yeah it's in it's McKee does every
electrical he just [ __ ] everything
and I would just sit there I watched all
of that I watched all the way back to
people rebuilding like flathead v8 and
what made it a flathead and I never got
any electrical that always seemed like
magic to me like I never got into that
[ __ ] I was scared like oh you touch it
you get [ __ ] electrocuted but I got
all into like watching like like
somebody rebuild an engine like just
from the bottom to the top it just
wasn't a lot of stuff right it was like
the crankshaft and then there was the
[ __ ] that held on the Pistons he put the
drop two Pistons in and then there was
the intake was at the intake manifold
and another was the the big thing the
valves see gapping the valves that
seemed like out man if you [ __ ] that up
this thing isn't gonna run right and and
just knowing that the firing thing and I
got into like torque wrenches and I
learned how to change brakes on like a
like old-school like shoe brakes and
stuff like that I got all the right
wrenches and all that I don't know how
to adjust them I know where you do this
is little slit in the back of the wheel
and I thought you just put them close to
it you spits right up against the drum
you're supposed to put them on and I got
totally into [ __ ] brakes for a while
I tried to rebuild
the carburetor failed miserably cuz it
was really old and I took off too many
parts it was like warped and [ __ ] so was
that you dodge the truck now for it it's
good for ya ya ones afford a black it's
black yeah yeah nothing was brown I
don't know what years I like 60 68 who's
made I looked up the VIN number it was
actually made in Canada crazy and March
of 68 I want to say Toronto or something
like that like that I guess they had a
factory up there or whatever so in March
of 1968 that thing rolled off and I
think it spent most of its life down
south like in Georgia did you swap the
brakes out for disc brakes I did i Chris
Titus was the one who helped me with
that
he put I did one side he did the other
but he did the other but he showed me I
was just doing what he told me to do so
I had all drum brakes and I wanted to
keep it all original but you know people
were pulling out in front of me like I
had disc brakes I'll tell you what's
[ __ ] hilarious when I only had drum
brakes I locked him up one time in front
of a bunch of Millennials and they've
never heard that sound that they all
went like that and all I was doing I
just you know the light turn you know
fast the yellow lights are out here I
was kind of an East Coast mindset like I
can make this no I can't and I just
[ __ ] I didn't think I hit him that
hard I kind of went a little sideways
and then it was [ __ ] hilarious is
like this outdoor cafe and they all
looked over and then I just had to
[ __ ] sit there it was almost like
that Artie Lange movie when he [ __ ]
mooned he moons the crowd and the guy
gets out and just leaves in there he's
like oh he was he was supposed to keep
going like that's like actually
embarrassed I probably waved and said
sorry those brakes were terrible it's
amazing nobody died or more people
didn't die rather those brakes I used to
have a 1970 Barracuda that had those
kind of brakes
oh yeah I know just 71 when I was in
high school and you'd hit the brakes and
they were just skid I mean there was
everything locked up yeah that lock
breaks one of the greatest inventions
yes
[ __ ] incredibly I mention know I used
to drive my truck before I had power
steering I got put power steering in an
air conditioning it was just like just a
basically a farm truck and it was like
no power steering three on the column
which
I still have because I think that's cool
and I used I got stuck in the teeth of
the love one night like the [ __ ] you
know traffic I always said stuck I'm
driving through the teeth of it be like
between five and seven I was coming from
Santa Monica driving over to the [ __ ]
Laugh Factory and I literally by the
time I got to the Laugh Factory I was
like tired man I know I'm an older guy
but just like shifting and like you know
like well yeah when you're at a dead
stop and you're just turning the [ __ ]
weight of that and this is giant
steering wheel to give you like leverage
that's why the [ __ ] thing is so big
and I was just like oh my god like I you
know doing a three-point turn and that
like my triceps would be burning not in
the best shape but I'm just saying it's
like I got to make my life a little
easier even my little car that little
red car that I have that doesn't have
any power steering and when I when I
turned that thing that car is so light
and tiny it's [ __ ] hard to turn
though like when I have to pull into the
parking lot of the Comedy Store and I
have to back it up so that I could get
out of there quick yeah it's a pain in
the dick it's yeah three-point turns are
not three-point turn it's like four or
five points yeah I wonder if back in the
day cuz those those original cars they
had those little skinny bike tires on it
it was it was just easier to turn and
then is they got like heavier and wider
well you know my Corvette has that
modern suspension on that 65 Corvette
and it has really wide tires he's a big
ol steamrollers just for a goof I had
the power steering taken off I'm like
let's see what it's like to have the
power steering that's [ __ ] horrible
it was horrible like you'd get a forearm
workout just driving around driving on
the street yeah yeah yeah you're
bouncing around it was too much I had to
change it back yeah I have old cars
though there's something about the idea
that you could fix it you could go in
there and with a good book or a good
video you can actually fix it you know I
know a lot of guys would fix things I
know guys have changed their
transmission they've gone in there and
swapped their transmission out for a new
one you know it's just balls to take it
apart and then the patients like I don't
you got to ask for help and like I just
found like it was just like and like I
need what tool I don't have the [ __ ]
tool then you have to order it was
really frustrating and that was a quick
sort of like rabbit hole I went down so
I like now that I kind of understand how
the whole thing comes together
but like yeah I guess that gets back to
the whole going down the rabbit hole
thing there's a guy who's got a great
video that you would love and it's on
petrol ish as' and it's the videos
called I think it's called
a one-car for everything and this is God
mm he's a fiction writer mm-hmm Brett's
like screenplays and [ __ ]
never worked on a car in his life
decided to want to buy an old Porsche so
he bought like a 1971 Porsche and didn't
know jack [ __ ] about cars so he starts
learning one called car to do it all
that's it so this guy puts together this
car and then starts working on it and
then takes his [ __ ] garage and turns
his garage into like a professional
workspace digs a hole in the ground puts
a lift in in the floor of his garage
like blaze cement does everything this
guy married Wow
doesn't seem like yeah it doesn't seem
like he's gonna do with that old car
what this is the car it's a beautiful
car look at that thing I'd love those
old and that's you know my little car is
71 that looks like a nineteen late 70s
to me no it's a flat no a flat hood the
the long hood rather the long hood
models are like 68 67 68
- like 73 that's his name Jack Olsen
it's a really [ __ ] cool video because
this is a guy that didn't have any
background in it that's his [ __ ]
garage he built all this he built the
whole garage and he just decided look I
just slowly get into it and understand
it and he has different arrow like see
that giant wing that's arrow that he
puts on only when he's at the racetrack
so he can unbolt it and do it he uses
this car for everything he uses this car
to go get groceries yeah yeah that's
that's that looks like yeah it's a
[ __ ] beautiful car those cars are so
light to their cars like mm did he he
flared out the fenders all right no no
the RS are from that era had no fenders
yeah Wow
yeah well they had to have fat rear
fenders and fat rear tires because the
engines in the back and those things
snap around when you take in turns
because the balance is way off like the
engine is hanging out behind the rear
wheels it's not a mid-engine car it's a
rear-engine car which is extremely rare
and the only Porsche really does it and
so you get something called lift
throttle oversteer when you're in a turn
you have to keep the the pedal on you
have to keep the gas going when you're
in a turn if you let off the turn your
rear end just pops out and you you get
oversteer you spin around in a circle so
they used to call the turbos
widow-makers because the way they used
to have those old cars they used to have
those really shitty tires like that like
he's got new modern compound tires on
that thing so it probably sticks like
glue but the old tires were [ __ ] they
were terrible so you'd have this super
powerful engine the weird dynamics where
the engines hanging out behind the axle
I never thought about that yeah talking
so much fun to drive there's so much fun
it is so engaging
I love taking it to the store because by
the time I get to the store like my
brains firing it's like popping because
I've been shift in there it's like a
Nicole it's air-cool you know it's not a
very like that red car is not a very
fast car like a modern car you're
Tesla's way faster than it is but it's
what it is is it alive it's like make it
feel the gears like when you shift in
put that sucker in a second it's just
very visceral you know yeah I drove
buddies Tesla one time that was [ __ ]
ridiculous
I just asked ya know my head was
tingling like I said blood rush into the
back and he just had the one motor and
every guy I know that has Tesla a
handful handful I should say they all
got invited to the factory when they got
the motor on the front wheel and the
back wheel and all of them said no to
that car going dude I would [ __ ] die
if I got that it's like almost like
Superbike motorcycle fast yeah like a
racing motorcycle level fast it's zero
to 60 in like to point something seconds
and then they have that new one that
roadster that's coming out that's one
point something seconds one point
something seconds zero to 60 yeah you're
in a missile I mean it's the only way to
put it like God forbid somebody's foot
slips off the brake
the gas yeah you're gonna obliterate a
street full of people that's [ __ ]
crazy it is crazy
it's bad enough somebody does that on a
bike you can do that on a car with all
that weight and those tehsils a heavier
[ __ ] cuz of that battery I guess which I
didn't really I think I would think cuz
there was no power train or anything
yeah that it would be lighter but I
guess that battery is like super heavy
there or [ __ ] and they don't make any
noise
yeah which is even weirder so they're
coming at you you don't even know yeah
they're kind of lost but I don't you
know I don't like the front end there's
no grill like the front end is boring it
is kind of boring kind of boring I think
yeah it's like the new one isn't the
Roadster I've seen the Roadster can I
promote another Patrice yeah [ __ ] yeah
what it's February 19th look at this
annual Tesla's new emissions testing
mode will produce loud nasty farts on
demand
it makes fart added a fart app this week
oh that's so ridiculous it's got seven
different parts there are six different
fart sounds than one automatic you can
you can set it to like different buttons
like a turn signal and so it makes
sounds and then it makes smell to no
smell it's that it's just the sound
emission oh okay okay that's just stupid
anyways the Patrice O'Neal car that
farts when is the Ben Fabri wery 19th at
the New York City Center and what do we
got here I shut off my damn phone we got
a Michelle wolf Michelle wolf Jim
Gaffigan I got it here and I already
forget Sipho sounds myself rich Voss
it's all coming back here big Jay big
Jay oakerson Gary Gulman
Chris red that's a [ __ ] yes sir hello
we're gonna try to add a couple more
people to it it's at the New York City
Center Tuesday February 19th all
proceeds go to his family and it's been
such a great thing like his you know his
mom's been able to get a condo and
everything just told because he was
taking we basically with that thing we
take care of everybody that he was taken
care of because you know we you know the
mission was basically all his family
should have to deal with is the grief
right you know I always think that
that's enough and the reason why we
continue to do it every year is because
his family members are still you know
alive and I always hated that when
somebody died is to say hey we do one
time right there's a sack of money
trying to make this last for the next 32
sixty years of your lives you know and
and then also because you know he was
the best stand-up that I ever saw alive
and just keeping his name you know I
always think that when anytime somebody
says oh you're one of the top bla bla
bla bla bla bla and I always think well
you know Patrice and Hedberg and all of
these [ __ ] guys do Freddy soda what
he would have done
yes thinking about Freddy I was just
thinking about that when you said that
that maybe we should do one of those for
Freddy's family yeah Freddy was like he
was brilliant oh and he was worried he
would imitate his dad shake garlis no it
was like it was like yeah he would like
hurt the crowd it was like he was a
stopped [ __ ] guy - yeah he was every
time you saw Freddy Soto he's all about
hugs oh there's a good dude I'm buddy
last time I saw him we were working and
remember the Aspen Comedy Festival yeah
I remember yeah
and I didn't see him the last couple
years maybe I saw him out in LA but that
was the time that I remembered because
we were kind of in the same group you
know group group a or whatever so yeah
he was walking around I think was buying
something for his wife or his kid or
something like that I yeah that one
Jesus you know you heard so many was
when I was just like Freddy yeah Freddy
died I couldn't believe that sleep apnea
apparently sleep apnea and pills to go
to sleep you know I take ambien if you
have sleep apnea and lock up and you
just stop breathing sleep apnea is a
real [ __ ] problem I have it I take a
mouthpiece I put a mouthpiece in at
night when I go to sleep but it keeps my
tongue from falling back on my throat a
lot of athletes have it the bigger your
neck gets the more muscle tissue you
have in your neck the more it closes off
your air hole when you go to sleep like
there's a lot of meat in there well stop
filling the next [ __ ] then dude what are
you doing a barbell just tie it to the
side of your [ __ ] head effective
working out you just get a big net dude
you do these no one can strangle you
that is what it is for real like well
someone can definitely still strangle
you but it helps a lot like if you get
ahold of a regular neck regular necks
just comply they just give you please
call your next special regular neck
I guarantee no one's gonna try and
accidentally take that title that's true
regular neck regular neck joe rogan
regular neck it's hard coming up with a
good name for a special are you do
somebody told me you were doing are we
saying that you're gonna do your next
one independent you're gonna do it
independent um no I don't know how I'm
gonna do it I'm exploring all like the
options and all of that I'm trying I was
trying to figure out a way to you know
cuz it's just a ton of specials out
there was just trying to figure out a
way but I mean the you know when was
last time we filmed October 2016 so um
Dom do I'm doing I'm but it's like am I
do I don't know I don't know like I
don't I don't it's it's what it is is
the special has changed since you and I
started yeah we're special was special
now what it is is it's just kind of an
an hour long advertisement letting
people know that you're still out there
and and it's like this just doesn't it
documents your stuff though yeah it does
it but this is just such a sheer amount
of stuff to see to have like an impact
the way like I was trying to think maybe
the last one that really was just like
whoa and I would say would be like maybe
Dave Chappelle killing him softly
certainly Chris Rock bringing the pain
where it was just like you know I'm not
saying that weren't ones that like like
people talked about but like just that
thing where like do you remember when we
were kids it was just like you know
Friday hey man see you on Monday and
then somehow on Monday everybody saw
delirious where everybody saw dice or
everybody saw Sam Kinison on the the
Dangerfield thing and it was just like
no one was talking about it and then
just like there was only so many
channels and that thing just caught
enough people's eye and you came to
school Monday and everyone was just
talking about it like you know I'm still
getting [ __ ] tweets from people saying
hey I finally got around to watching
Breaking Bad do you know what I mean
like I was talking about the wire one
time they're like dude you could have
said spoiler alert it's like that [ __ ]
went off the air in like 2006
like how much time do I have to give you
to watch it you know so um I still
haven't seen the wire do my buddy his uh
his son the number one thing that he
watches is he on his phone he's watching
one of these guys that gets paid to play
video games he watches this guy on his
phone play video games everybody does
that
okay sober common yes so now that's
another thing to watch exact forget
about online porn and [ __ ] me
watching eric the car guy and all that
trying to trying to like find like where
you can like drop the pamphlets of your
career basically to be like hey man i'm
still around
i think there's definitely more content
now than ever before but for in terms of
like the amount of stand-up that's
available there's never been more great
stand-up available to watch yeah like to
think about how many specials there are
now i mean it's fun it's [ __ ] crazy
yeah really is it is it's yeah so
they're not really specials they're not
specials they're not specials because
because it used to be specials used to
be the top comics now right arguably it
was basically the top light male comics
so the fact that they fixed that is a
great thing but now is it though I mean
Chris Rock Dave Chappelle Damon Wayans
yeah dude there was a lot of there was a
lot of white guys there was a lot of
white guys was a lot of great black guys
too and really the real problem was
women there wasn't very many women yeah
I mean there's like women in like three
stations there's Apaches there's other
people out there don't stay on
obsessions
there's gotta be anyways but what I'm
saying was but it was the best of the
best where now it's just everybody it's
everybody right right so like I remember
when it was changing well I was doing a
club and the feature rack was
complaining that he didn't get a
half-hour special on one of these
networks and I'm thinking like you're a
feature act I'm like what do you what
are you gonna do you're gonna do your
whole act and you're still a feature and
you want to document that and it's just
like they used to give out half our
specials when I started out and it was
to like guys who had been on the road
for like 15 years and they were
taken from their headlining hour they
will take in half of that like the best
bits from an hour and then you know and
that somehow through time just became a
feature going up and doing his whole act
well Netflix is doing that now they have
the degenerate special they have big J
did one Joey Diaz did one christina
pazsitzky did one I'm not saying it's
bad I'm just saying it's changed right
so because it's it's even changed since
my last special that I put out my last
advertisement that I put out our long
advertising so you just try to figure
out because everything's just [ __ ]
changing so fast you're just trying to
navigate like where can I put this in
all of this right that it's gonna blink
enough that someone's gonna stare at it
and maybe like watch the thing I just
noticed you [ __ ] lights with this guy
that's pretty critical right yes well
that was the company that makes those
octo lights shout-out to octo lights
yeah Gaffigan did an interesting thing
he decided not to put his newest one on
Netflix he puts it on everything it's on
Hulu and Amazon you can get it on iTunes
but not Netflix yeah he's a smart guy
well I just took a chance I guess you
know just decided to see what happens if
you just make it available everywhere
instead yeah like to talk to him see how
successful that was yeah I'll uh because
I'm still working out my stress I'll
talk to you off here but because I don't
want cuz it flex with my I get it
ability to yeah you know make something
happen so I'll tell you what my idea was
but I got nixed I've thought about doing
and just put it right on YouTube I've
thought about doing that before not
getting paid for it just shoving it
right on YouTube just see what happens
yeah and you too yeah yeah yeah just
paying for it and just sticking it out
there because if it is an advertisement
what's the best way to get it out there
well the best way would just be to put
it on YouTube right and then to segment
it into like little chunks so that
people could digest it and yeah it's
people wind up doing that
I don't think Netflix takes them down I
think when you have bits up that like
from specials that that go up on Netflix
I think Netflix just lets them stay up
it just depends on what year
what your contract is is you can work
that in we did a special with Paul virzi
all things coming up work we did a
special with him which was did
phenomenal like broke all their online
streaming records and it was great
because he was a guy that they don't
really give special to his right right
now you know who did he do this special
for Comedy Central
oh yeah and so the the streaming version
was really successful yeah I mean he did
well on well now trying to get people to
actually just [ __ ] sit down and watch
television like everybody tape you tape
[ __ ] right that's just how it works
which is now if you watch like NFL games
they have this thing now where the games
going on and all of a sudden the game
slides to the left and then there's two
boxes and the advertising box is bigger
because they know that everybody's
taping games and they're blowing through
it and advertisers somehow can tell if
someone fast forwarded through and then
that they the NFL doesn't make as much
money so now they're they're running
like this is weird I think these two
things you don't really have to look at
the commercial you can just sit there
looking at the game but then they're
telling you about [ __ ] whatever at
the same time yeah it's weird that's
gross it's gross but is it I mean that's
how you know I think money off
advertising it's like my thing and
what's gross is is how your what you
know if you dump and [ __ ] in the water
supply if you got like all kinds of like
you know I mean I think they all have
some sort of labor [ __ ] issues I
would like that I would like to be able
to pay to not have that like if I could
Amazon one click them like how much I
gotta give you for each game well I
don't have to see that yeah but they
will think but what the advertisers will
do is their pockets are deeper and then
they're gonna go big they're gonna find
like what's funny is when the internet
started out all of a sudden you just you
went from watching seeing all these
commercials to like nothing to now
seeing way more than you ever saw yeah
like my the worst is when you're
watching a long youtube video and then
all of a sudden it just stops and you
know they try to make make a nice break
and then you just watch this and it
annoys me but I'm like well I do
advertise on my podcast how upset about
this can I get you know I
you see when you look at the line and
you see those little yellow lines on the
YouTube video where you know that's
where the [ __ ] ads are gonna pop up
there no I didn't know that yeah isn't
that how it works yeah yeah yeah I mean
look
advertising is what it is I mean it's
either that or you do like a patreon
type deal when you have people
contribute like Sam Harris does that
right you know it doesn't you know
there's a million ways to do it but like
I don't get mad at advertising because
like I said a stand-up specials me
advertising then I'm gonna be out on the
road you say that but it's not it's
entertainment it's people that watch it
they can enjoy it like okay thinking
about it that what there's a way also to
do advertising entertainingly like way
back those less filling tastes great but
like a lot Miller like commercials were
[ __ ] great funny yeah you were great
and you wanted to see him and you loved
him or at least I did
so yeah this way is there's ways to do
everything they still have some good
commercials like what's that insurance
lady who's always in those commercials
what is that flow yeah flow she's she's
[ __ ] funny there's some funny
commercials still but it's you know it's
hard I know Seinfeld was actually
thinking about opening up an insurance
agency at one point time cuz he
apparently likes writing stuff like that
and he was literally thinking Oh an
advertising agency what I'd say
insurance man [ __ ] yeah advertising he
was thinking about doing that at one
point in time yeah about making ads bet
he's probably like wait a minute I don't
have a real job yeah it's like how much
mine do I need yeah guys like that make
me feel normal
with like car collecting like when I
went to Jay Leno's place he's got 11
buildings filled with cars Mike oh okay
I see where this goes yes yes he is I've
never been over there but he has he has
enough cars to start his own traffic jam
on the he could fill up the 405 one side
of it I would think he could fill up the
Pasadena Rose Bowl you can fill up the
[ __ ] parking lot it's ridiculous I'll
take you you want to go yeah but I love
it does he have bring your truck does he
have more
cars than days of the year oh yeah cuz I
know he also has like motorcycles he
said it he's got that hon that's another
one that's another one I went down a
rabbit hole is uh was it Jays garage
yeah yeah great show oh yeah I loved it
no I I yeah I got into all a gas monkey
garage
Jay's garage getting that gas monkey guy
on the show oh my Richard Rawlings yeah
I just got an email yesterday yeah [ __ ]
yeah that guy's a [ __ ] right I love
that guy
ask him about my favorite episode my
favorite [ __ ] episode of that cuz he
always like I watch that show so much I
knew the number who's gonna come at like
they'd be like okay what do you want for
this gone and he always get them to say
it first maybe like I mean I was I was
thinking like five grand and then he'd
be all I could do I could do like 2,700
right and then the [ __ ] guy would
then go down to four grand and he would
come up like like 300 bucks and he
didn't get in the car for like three
grand like whatever the [ __ ] you wanted
right so one time he went out and he
busted this guy down on like a old Trans
Am or a Firebird or some [ __ ] I forget
what the guy sells it to him for like
[ __ ] he wanted like eighteen grand or
something he sold it to him for like 11
so he [ __ ] gets the car over there
he's talking or he's gonna do a lot with
it and all of a sudden the guy's brother
calls up and says hey that guy didn't
have the [ __ ] right to sell that car
that's also mine you got a you know I'm
gonna come down I gotta buy it back from
you so the guy comes down and he's you
know ask him what he wants for it and
Richards just like I mean I was thinking
like 20 and the guy goes he goes dude
you bought it for my brother I know what
you paid for it he actually got the only
time I ever saw him get like embarrassed
he wasn't he just went into like his his
thing and like I swear to God like
watching that show like you get better
at like negotiating and like and I think
occasionally he does like these sketches
to where he he'll do like a character
imitating like an old-school used-car
salesman and you just how good he does
it yeah cuz you know it's like he's a
performer
do anything how good he does is like
this guy is like this is just in his
blood he's just been a car guy
he's been flipping cars yeah I'm trying
to be I've seen the show in a minute but
like he used to talk about how he you
know by the time he was like 19 he was
on like his 30th car or something like
he was just like I'll buy this car like
that one even just every month would
just flip them those cars there's
something about those shows that if
those an auction shows or any time like
pawnshop shows there's something about
wanting to know how the deal plays out
yeah you know that is so compelling for
people there's something I like and I'm
a [ __ ] I'll just sit there staring like
how much they gonna get yeah how much
they gonna get for that yeah whoo that
Civil War coins
what are those worth and how much they
buff sat down and just like yeah I mean
that guy Richards probably the best I've
seen
he's the most entertaining because he's
like a fun guy to watch it's a
performance yeah he's a oh man i mean i
was thinkin oh yeah and then he goes up
to and he pulls out this giant wad it's
like dude you had it you had the money
the other guy asked to sit there and
watch it then he kind of makes fun of
him afterwards yeah you know you kind of
make you know in a funny like a funny
way or whatever but um it's a funny
thing too that how appealing that is to
men like I bet if you looked at the
number of women who watched those car
shows versus the number of Motor Trend
has a channel now they've their own
channel and I guarantee that is 97
percent dudes and three percent women
complaining teepees have women going
what the [ __ ] are you watching like if
you look at the actual numbers like what
is it about cars like girls can drive
cars girls drive cars all the time
girls like cars they don't like cars
away guys like cars it's just most of
them generally speaking yeah I'll sound
like Danica Patrick and a few psychos
yeah I met her one time yes I picture
with you yes you did she took me around
the Indianapolis Motor Speedway's no
coming down that straightaway and seen
like you know where they had the
leaderboard and everything was iconic
and I've been to that race a couple of
times so it was crazy
that's we going she ended all she only
went like half the speed of what the car
like how fast they would be going at
some point we got up to maybe like 140
but we were like going around
and like my face was doing this but what
I loved about her was she had like
test-pilot vibe yeah like she came up
and was just vice-like handshake and
she'd beast yeah it was pretty uh hey
guys yeah she was just totally like
looking look at that little difference
on her sunglasses and my sunglasses I
definitely look live passionately so you
know what are you talking about they
look the same no no no those are like
right off the [ __ ] Delft what's wrong
with your sunglasses worse or hers like
you'll see it it's all in the details
come on man it's like we you know I I
probably you know your Crescent kick
probably looks the same as [ __ ] some
guy in a strip mall to me I mean I glare
as you say Crescent that's one of the
rarest kicks
anybody ever pulls off it's left over
from the 80s whatever but that's kind of
legit Crescent kicks kind of [ __ ] I
don't think about Meachem is after a
while it just all becomes like she'll be
good morons yeah yeah and hammies Hemi
Cuda we got a Hemi Cuda coming up and
Plum Crazy
those [ __ ] things are too much you
but you buy those things for a million
dollars and when their car came out it
was like 20 grand
I mean not even I like I like weird [ __ ]
yeah I like you know I want to get a 76
GMC RV that's what I want to go on the
road with yeah then they had this thing
was I think it was called pom pom desert
green or something like that it was like
this total Ron Burgundy
and that thing was way ahead of its time
that's not a piece of [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] tremendous something you walk
off stage and get on that [ __ ] thing
you feel like a king you got a driver
what do you give a [ __ ] you don't give a
[ __ ] about anything I could be on the
road forever in that just making eggs on
that little stovetop now you're in there
drinking you're doing what you want
you're watching Goodfellas the [ __ ]
anchorman that is pretty beautiful it's
so blessed experience - you're riding in
that thing you're that's a retro
experience it's not just my truck yeah
that thing I you know my wife nixed it
it's like wait are you gonna put it
the [ __ ] driver will keep it I don't
need it
she was right my wife's always right not
always but mostly women don't like when
you collect [ __ ] like where you gonna
put that they don't like that you get
too many things you know half the reason
why I got this place collect [ __ ] here
oh yeah nobody can seen nothing the spot
woman says nothing
no but then it becomes you spend more
time down there than you do up here I
don't though I've got it I got it nailed
I figured it out
get up early you being such a jerk
that's why they don't have a point I
don't actually I can actually refute
your opinion your point or whatever it's
so universal to all women have that
response like [ __ ] is wrong with you
yeah yeah we had a highway yeah
that's it well imagine being them
watching you imagine being a woman have
taken care of your children you know you
give birth you have this little tiny
infant and then financially you're
relying on this [ __ ] maniac it's out
there flying helicopters and fixing cars
and you know playing drums all day it's
like what are you long as the money
keeps coming in they can't say anything
but they're like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
the end of the day you're married an
eight-year old comedian oh Jesus Christ
yeah you're lucky we got drug addicts
yeah yeah no I'm I'm uh I got a I got a
work on myself man I got a [ __ ] you
know I just yeah I am a difficult person
to live with evidently I didn't realize
it but like I'm now looking at it
honestly stepping back and look I got
yeah I can see that oh [ __ ] see that
yeah I've thought about it
I'm definitely difficult well if you
don't think about it that remind you
about it yeah I mean I just imagine
relying on me I mean I'm reliable
like I'm not I want to be like if you
you could have married the me that
worked in a [ __ ] warehouse and I
would have been the same thing you know
and it we would be in a [ __ ] studio
apartment here's the deal though they
went to married yet huh
yeah yeah yeah if you were just [ __ ]
off never got your [ __ ] together you
notice about lemon - is their ability to
move on yeah whoa that guy though I've
always said like if I ever [ __ ] died
how quickly all my clothes would be it
down at the goodwill you know and she
just be like you know sell the house
let's just burn some sage yeah that was
interesting
all right well my dust to the plate all
my discussions with biologists and
people who study like what's God's ads
what is his discipline behavioral
psychology but he studies you know his
GAD sad is that last name as his
fullness aad G ad that's his first name
GAD aad is his last name it doesn't
rhyme because it also rhymes Canadian
evolutionary behavioural scientist
brilliant guy he was so in Lebanon does
his name still rhyme that's a good
question is there anywhere he can go no
me just my name is GAD said no he calls
himself the Godfather he's like oh so he
just steered into it he's a great guy
I can't matter he's 13 but brilliant on
this dad sad I don't think sad means the
same thing over there you know
differently but in a day it rhymes
there's no country you can be on you
could be on that [ __ ] little island
where they shot that guy with the arrows
and they're going to make fun of you sir
probably kick you off the island yeah
you can't name you keep like some of
these celebrities some of the [ __ ]
names they name their kids it's just
like
don't you remember school if you don't
remember how [ __ ] mean kids were why
are you giving they a point painting a
[ __ ] buy get it you're creative yeah
have a meditation room [ __ ] don't do
that with the name well give him a nice
bill named William this is folding chair
Johnson
people need to express themselves they
do it through the naming of their
children my other favorite thing that
what they do is when they [ __ ] they
put their political agenda on them like
that kid doesn't even have a [ __ ]
chance like this whole thing like
gender roles babies by the way that my
little experience being a dad going to
kid birthday parties they those kids are
not old enough for that behavior to be
learned dude the kids come the boys show
up it is [ __ ] Braveheart they come
over the [ __ ] Hill they the girls are
social they're sitting there that kind
of the taking things in you know the
kids boys coming they [ __ ] dude up we
were at one on Saturday and there was
this this kid who's hilarious he looked
like a little Bobby Hurley he's a point
guard right and he was playing this game
he had like this ball and he was using
his his like forums as a bat and he was
hitting and then he would catch it then
he would throw it between his legs he
was doing all its kids hand-eye
coordination was great for his age so
over in the corner where I was sitting
with my daughter was these like little
like sort of like cushions that someone
had put together like three piece thing
and made it into like a little chair for
someone an old person like me could sit
down so I stood up because I was worried
the ball was gonna hit so it's kind of
guarding that so he went over and got
the ball at one point and just seeing
the chair there you know all built like
that he just saw it and just kicked it
just destroyed it and then continued on
I think like why did he do that this is
a boy he's a boy yeah we like ruined
[ __ ] well you got a lot of energy little
kids like need something to do that's
physical their little bodies have the
little little batteries overflowing with
energy just saying that their [ __ ] was
all about like grabbing throwing
breaking yeah breaking yeah do you
remember being a kid yeah but he did
that yeah so this one this whole thing
of like like well women aren't
aggressive like that because you know a
standards yeah I think it's they're
aggressive in like I think that they
literally from like just survival [ __ ]
they're looking and like alright that's
what I have to compete with and there
are you see them looking at the boys who
appear to be dominating and what they
are is they're actually showing all of
their cards and the little girls are
already taken and in breaking them down
knowing well I can't get physical with
this person I can't like dominate this
person physically this is definitely and
they just immediately stuck on like
that's why they're [ __ ] smarter than
we are
I think no lose you're somewhere that I
don't necessarily think they're smarter
I think what's going on is that men have
we have different DNA and that the the
genes are aggressive and men never be
doing on reckless [ __ ] right that's I'm
just saying it's not society didn't sit
down until they didn't watch three
cereal commercials and then be like oh I
need to be [ __ ] this I just think
that's that's just some [ __ ] that
adults comment came up with and it's not
just adults it's almost always women
it's women that think that there's
something wrong with the way men are
raising their sons they think there's
something like that this idea of these
men raising these kids these kids being
aggressive is because the way they're
being coached that's not true it's just
that's just a part of being a boy this
is a but [ __ ] ton of studies if people
wanted to actually look at the science
if you leave boys alone with toys and
girls alone with toys boys will
gravitate towards trucks and [ __ ] you
know things that they can hit and smash
and girl sit down there with little
teacups and they play with dolls it's
natural it's just a hundred percent
natural yeah there's a documentary on
babies well you know what babies are
gender neutral the raising their kids
gender neutral so they don't call them a
boy or a girl and my thing with that is
there's no way you're not saying to your
son you're sure you don't want to wear
the dress and then the kid wants to
[ __ ] and once the parents approval
yeah I didn't want that football I guess
I wanted the dress and it's just like
like I said you know my kids barely 2 so
what the [ __ ] do I know I'm just saying
my limited experience at kids birthday
parties is it's not even how it was ever
even questioned that like they're too
[ __ ] too young the [ __ ] year and a
half two years old like the you telling
me that society has already yeah they
have it's ridiculous but it's it's
usually women that want to push this and
men who are [ __ ] it's like these
these men that don't like are the roars
they don't like aggressive men they
don't
like manly men and so they they push it
as well no because they are aggressive
and they're controlling and they want to
run [ __ ] and that's because that's the
thing where it like if you really look
at their agenda when they say the future
is feminine that's not inclusive and
they're and they're all about I'll make
this more inclusive it's like no let us
in so we can take it over and then we'll
push you down is is the psychology of
the kind of person that goes after that
someone that's after like power I'm not
saying the average woman is like that my
wife is a feminist and she's into like
inclusive [ __ ] but like people who are
spearheading stuff yes like those people
are wired the same way like you know I
mean a Dominator is yes yes and there's
gonna be no room for you it's gonna be
like think the way like a lot of that
that so-called progressives extreme left
is think the way we think say what we
say or we will [ __ ] destroy you pull
up that tweet that i retweeted today the
david pakman retweet david pakman is is
liberal progressive guy
this woman posts on Twitter she would
never vote for a man or a white white
man or a white person white why is
someone who's white or male he says
that's racist and sexist it is so she
blocks him on Twitter today she called
Boston College demanding that they not
have him back as adjunct faculty it's
crazy so this woman post this and he
points out that it's racist and sexist
so she blocks him and she tries to get
him fired okay that this is why that
whole thing is [ __ ] up okay because
he's acting like white people exist on
an even plane which is what a lot of
people try to do so it's like he's not
necessarily he's just saying that what
she's saying is racist and sexist yes
because she's determining who she's
gonna vote for based entire on the race
but there's other elements involved like
the level that white people not saying
all white people but why people have
[ __ ] over people who are not white
forget about poor white people who they
[ __ ] over so you understand that but
they're both right but then like the
fact that she then takes it to the point
that because he had the audacity to have
a difference of an opinion that that's
the thing
now we're gonna destroy you and you
can't be on this thing and then the
other level of that is how the corporate
entities are so afraid that one [ __ ]
nickel is gonna roll out the dough
because all of this [ __ ] is you're just
a paper tiger until you get the big
behemoth to listen to you and there's
all of these these [ __ ] things from
award shows to this [ __ ] that
someone just needs to be like listen
this guy already apologized this is this
is an old [ __ ] thing or look you just
had a difference of opinion that you
know this isn't the first time you're
gonna say something and somebody's gonna
disagree with you that doesn't mean that
this guy can't come back you know and
you obviously because of some [ __ ]
that's happened to you have an extreme
opinion about this guy because of the
color of his skin it's like there's so
many fucked-up elements to that that but
for some reason you can't like if you
address that on any level then you're
part of the problem and that's not just
part of the problem a she's trying to
get him fired she's trying to get him
fired for pointing out that something is
racist not saying if you say what I just
says try to look at it 360 oh yeah and
you're as much as I can which is why I
love South Park is everything that they
do they do it 360 right and so I learned
a lot from that show by the way they
look at stuff like that because I don't
[ __ ] know everything but even just to
try to be like well hey you know you
know you salted them a little bit I
understand what you're saying and blah
blah you can't [ __ ] do that anymore
cuz then so I mean you're part of the
[ __ ] problem and no it's really
getting crazy got to the point like I've
seen like a name names but I've seen
like you know a tweet from a fellow
comic telling comics what jokes you
shouldn't talk about this topic it's
like who the [ __ ] are you I say there's
already enough people doing that you're
gonna do like cannibalism now have you
really using comics sailorman real
comics yeah I mean everybody has their
opinion on somebody's [ __ ] act but I
mean yeah yeah that's ridiculous
that's not a real comic um well I
wouldn't say that they are real comic
they just have an opinion I don't agree
with they can [ __ ] off yeah I mean yeah
I mean
trying to have less confrontations of I
understand in my life here that kind of
[ __ ] drives me crazy though which drives
me most crazy is this bullying like
she's trying to get him fired try to get
him fired for having an opinion on
something that she publicly stated one
of these that somebody running one of
these things has to be like you know and
it can't just be private it has to be a
public tweet to say that this is it's
just going too far and this [ __ ]
thing where you have a difference of an
opinion now and they're just gonna you
know take your [ __ ] job away you know
I ran into this [ __ ] you know when you
know when the me to stuff first started
coming out people would try to like you
know you know you had to tweet the right
[ __ ] thing and if if you said
anything sort of oh let's let's look at
the evidence god forbid you [ __ ] said
that and it just became like this whole
you're part of the problem then they
would try to take you down or someone
you were you were friends with or doing
a show with are represented by they
would tried to do like that pressure to
try in and it was just like you know you
to say I was like no I'm not doing that
and then it just goes away cuz you know
the [ __ ] leg to stand on well also
the people that are doing it it's a
small percentage of it's a very
unbelievably small yeah unbelievably
small and the in you know comics it's
like we're literally running for office
we're out there campaigning you're in
for this election that never happens and
you're going through red states blue
states you're going through [ __ ]
everything and the general consensus of
people is like like dude that was
[ __ ] crazy like that that doesn't
make sense but no one wants to say it
because they're gonna get steamrolled
and we all saw what happened to Matt
Damon right Matt Damon said we have to
make a differentiation between the
Harvey Weinstein's in the world and then
someone who you know because he's on
sorry he goes on a bad date there's a
big difference between those two and
they attacked him they tried to get him
pulled off of that movie Ocean's eight
yeah and they were acting like that like
killing somebody versus stealing a car
versus jaywalking like that literally
the whole judicial system is based on
what you did is your punishment
your parents do that
right yeah and I mean you bad was what
you did yeah yeah that's all that's what
that sounded like that yeah he's exactly
we live in a world now I have to be
measured in the way that I say that what
he said you know affected me how I heard
it and then also this is just a typical
[ __ ] bald white male yeah and they
did they go in that route it's like
youyou literally sound like what the
[ __ ] you're against and it's it's a it's
not gonna last and I feel like it's like
the end of the winter and people want to
go outside and get some Sun on their
face and you didn't like no no like
taking people by the back of their
[ __ ] neck and [ __ ] shoving their
face in the [ __ ] it that you can't
sustain that no it doesn't because work
you don't get people to change by
yelling at them doesn't work or bombing
them like what the [ __ ] we're doing it
like yeah that's not all you're doing is
you just building up resentment yeah and
more people want to [ __ ] take you
down so that's like they don't
understand psychology so what they think
is this is their time this is their time
to get back at man this is their time to
yell at men this is it time to where the
future is feminine t-shirts this is a
time to take their stand and they did
you not see the women's March saw a
bunch of people walking all right listen
I'm not saying the points that they're
making don't need to be made I'm not
saying that their complaints are not
just it's it's the execution of it yes
where it's like you're gonna go through
intimidation and destroying people like
exactly people's careers and people you
have to publicly apologize it's so it's
like there's all young people yes some
of the biggest bullies right now I can't
believe it because I'm a lefty are on my
side of the [ __ ] fence and you know
when someone's on your side of the fence
and you're looking at them like you
sound like a [ __ ] crazy person that's
when you've entered like you know what
was your special strange times yeah
weird yeah like it's like it is strange
yeah it is strange because it's it's
they feel like they're justified because
they feel like with a maniac like Trump
in the office that they have to do what
they have to do to change the world but
you don't change the world by yelling at
people doesn't work that way and there's
this real points to be made as real
points about I couldn't imagine being a
woman working in an office with a bunch
of guys trying to [ __ ] you all the time
it's got to be a goddamn nightmare I
can't imagine having a bunch of bosses
that literally tell you you suck my dick
I'll give you a raise yeah yeah that
happens yes [ __ ] it's got to be hell
I get it I mean I guess but you have to
be you gotta be like 1/8 though eight on
up to deal with that every day I mean
let's be [ __ ] honest you know I mean
there's really there's really six is out
there this really good if you got person
to him a lot got a nice ass just say you
know it's just like some of that [ __ ] is
like [ __ ] you know it's it's that I
always viewed it like like you every
watch like they're behind the scenes of
like a prison and the first thing every
guy thinks is how the [ __ ] would I not
get raped in there right exam women have
to think that just yeah [ __ ] walking
down the street so that's how I wrap my
head around to be like wow okay like
what they saying is like cuz I I don't
like like like a lot of the arguments
and right like that doesn't make sense
it's what doesn't make sense to me is
the children of the corn
[ __ ] torches burning and just like
the way that this just I mean a lot of
people like they do that with like our
foreign policy like this whole [ __ ]
thing is bankrupt at this country every
August now they just shut down the
government which has just become normal
and all they do to to make it like okay
is they just raise the level of debt
that we legally can take on or whatever
and it's like I let's do this for
another year and if you question any of
that that means you don't support the
troops and you're a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] you need to get the [ __ ] out of
here and it's like so much stuff doesn't
make sense to me like I just saw
Michelle Obama
they had this [ __ ] tweet of her
wearing these glitter thigh-high boots
and said sets Twitter on fire with their
$4,000 [ __ ] boots and it's just like
you know did you
question where she got that money the
president makes 500 grand a year she
blew 4 grand on fly high boats and don't
even talk to me about the [ __ ] book
deal and all of that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
guy his first like to you know public
speaking engagement things were like
with major banks and you go out on the
roads the dock and all these guys are
like [ __ ] all these fellow Americans
are upside down in the house from those
[ __ ] banker [ __ ] who did not get did
not get punished in 2008 they all
shaming talk about like people who
should have that [ __ ] lives burned
down those people and these guys that
there and they have their faces in the
same [ __ ] pig trough it's the guys
with the red ties and for whatever
reason like I don't and I don't know why
like they get a pass exactly and it
doesn't make any sense how much more
serious [ __ ] like drone strikes more
more innocent civilians were killed with
drone strikes during Obama's
administration I know that's right
they're telling me you fighting
terrorism while you're creating more of
it because all I would want to do is
just get revenge
exactly and you know I have very
simplistic ways of how to get the [ __ ]
out of there how do you do it well I
mean I'm not saying the air would be
cleaner because I don't know what like
when you throw a Tesla battery into the
[ __ ] ocean what that does to it I'm
sure it's [ __ ] horrible but I know
that they're a one-stop shop over there
in the Middle East they got oil and
that's it
you know I always compare them remember
that kiosk in like the south shore Plaza
in Boston there was something it was a
place called wicks and sticks all they
did was sell candles which just seemed
like a really vulnerable business or
pewter pot they first they just sold
muffins and then they started doing full
breakfast well they'd like a pewter pot
that just selling muffins so if we stop
buying muffins and we got enough oil
here if we switch to solar power and all
that [ __ ] hell the windmills are ugly
and I know it's probably just as much
[ __ ] bad on the environment but what
it does is it gets you out of there and
it bankrupts them and then they don't
have the money to funnel through the
mosque to to fund the terrorists well
the United States is exporting oil now
which is crazy I mean we have a lot of
oil all right and especially through you
know probably I'm just saying but if you
ever suggested
yeah which I think I just did I think
then for some reason I don't love my
country and like I'm trying to solve it
I'm a frugal guy you know I don't
[ __ ] you know I don't spend beyond my
means and you know I don't like debt in
that type of [ __ ] I don't know how the
[ __ ] these guys I think that's why the
president age is so much
well then I'm gonna sleep the pressure
you imagine the dead bodies everything
all of that a [ __ ] is knowing how
everything really works oh yeah
Trump doesn't seem to mind he just takes
an extra adderall keeps on trucking
he doesn't seems like he's all the
scandals that guy seems complete cause I
think you he's a certain level sick
mentally that it doesn't it doesn't get
in I mean I because he hasn't aged at
all now granted he's got all that white
stuff around his eyes and you know I
don't know what he's doing with the hair
but the hair is usually the tell-tale
sign but I go gray yeah
it's one of the only presents that you
know it's like half of that shit's
probably from a doll like who knows
where that he's got enough money to do
like a transplant at this point I can't
do a transplant on that thing he's never
knee he doesn't have any donor area I
mean he's got it all in the back though
no he doesn't you ever see what happens
when it flies up in the back when the
wind hits it the backs all balled all
because he probably did the original
plugs and they didn't take who knows
what he's got going on back there he's
got chaos going on back there you ever
seen it yeah I mean he's the resin hits
it in his hair flops up but you ever
seen the video of him it looks look he's
a guy wearing a demon oh yeah like what
even wearing his mask
it's very wispy not just wispy like it's
missing look like look like glob a baby
do you know be nuts if he gets a second
term and he shaves his head there would
be nuts and he would just look like the
most evil [ __ ] dude ever like that
would be like if you got a second term
shaves his head starts doing
intermittent fasting lifting weights
gets on steroids drops down about a buck
90 jacked yeah I mean that would I think
yeah it's definitely I don't that's why
I'm trying to just in my own little
[ __ ] world I'm trying to chill out
more and I'm trying not to [ __ ]
there's just there's enough yelling I
don't think that they need it from me
now let's think more mocking and
laughing than yelling for sure but when
you see enough of those the future is
feminine t-shirts and you see enough
hypocrisy and you see enough people
trying to take people out for commenting
on what's sexist and racist and trying
to get people fired like it's a time of
outrage across the board and you have to
respond a little bit you have to let
people know hey this is [ __ ]
ridiculous like there's there's a
certain obligation
especially comedians have as a social
commentator you see some stupid [ __ ] if
you're not commenting on it there's if
you choose to go that some people just
like I'm just gonna let you forget your
whole workweek and I'm just and talk
about a bunch of [ __ ] small stuff like
Seinfeld type stuff yeah I mean some
people don't comment on anything that's
controversial some people they'll go
their entire career but what I've always
loved about Seinfeld is like if you
really listen to him he has contempt I
said this on the comedian's and cars he
has contempt for like 90% of things this
anger underneath this [ __ ] Bryan Regan's
like that to Brian Regan used to do that
[ __ ] bit about the cattle prod you
know the walk run walk stand line on the
on the the [ __ ] the moving sidewalk
at the airport when he would act out the
cattle prod that he wanted to [ __ ] do
I was just like there it is there it is
he's one of the nicest [ __ ] guys ever
Brian Regan he is so nice he's an
unbelievable just decent fully formed
human being he really is a great guy he
also knows when to get on stage when not
to get on stage if he's drunk he won't
get on stage oh yeah the other day he
was at the store he was hanging around I
had my show in the main room and they
said Brian you want to do a set he's
like thank you I've had a bit too much
to drink yeah it was in the back bar a
little bit lit up and he just said I
just don't think it's a good idea yeah
cos he's got that squeaky clean act if
he goes up there this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
hey can't you just can't I've only got
twice in my life I've been on stage
drunk once was in Ireland oh that's a
good place to be drunk yeah and then the
that's not doing the Kilkenny festival
along
go and then another time I had gone to a
Red Sox Yankees game got drunk at the
game thought it was sober and somebody
text me as I got back to the city going
hey you want to do a spot you know got
off the subway won't do a spot I was
like yeah and I thought you know you
know when you're so drunk that like just
drunk feel sober and I got on stage and
I was just like oh [ __ ]
and I really had to slow down I was like
slurring [ __ ] it was going on people
immediately everything I've learned it
as a comedian it was like I had like
opened my core energy and the whole
crowd reacted that way and I had to kind
of slow down and get it going I don't
think I did my time I was like [ __ ]
sweating my mouth was dry I was just
like alright that's it for me
that was my closing bit that's it for me
yeah so never did that again yeah it's
uh
anything that slows your brain down it's
not the best yeah but a little buzz
doesn't hurt anybody just a little bit
uh I don't
yeah we drink you like one drink yeah
drink I know you don't like anything no
I don't like I have like a rule that I
don't used to what right you used to
have like a drink before you go forever
no not even now it'll drink no never why
did I think you did no confusing you
with somebody maybe yeah so I know I'm
like I'm kind of just I don't know I I
was I drunk too much you know I was just
drank too much and then I just take some
time off so I'm just taking time off
from boozing right now I know you got on
a big diet kick for a while you got down
pretty light didn't ya
you go pretty heavy and then you lost a
ton of weight and you developed ABS
again I got four out of the eight I got
halfway there it's good I got halfway
there and then then I had a six-week run
on the road and it just [ __ ] it's
just sucks man I ate perfectly I wasn't
drinking for like two months now almost
three months and then six weeks six
weeks and you just [ __ ] you know it's
just it's just it's it's not fair it's
not fair that there's no way in a
healthy way to really lose like five
pounds a week but you can easily put on
six no problem no [ __ ] problem
especially in like New York you could
just [ __ ] you could do it you can
lose five pounds a week if you really
have the weight to lose I was gonna say
like I was gonna say tenth cuz I knew
you're gonna [ __ ] yeah that sounds rough
ten ten you're dehydrating yourself but
you can lose five no but I mean like not
losing muscle mass by just doing it the
right way and you're gonna keep it off
I'm not talking about some celebrity
crash diet or I gotta make weight for
this fight I mean like like legit just
how easy I mean Jesus [ __ ] New York
City get a couple slices of pizza every
[ __ ] night after a night of drinking
mm-hmm you're of a certain age that's it
five pounds all of a sudden you you know
[ __ ] slacks aren't fitting with this
boosting yeah yeah I do you ever do
intermittent fasting you know what that
is yeah you ever try that
yeah it's called sleeping I haven't
eaten for eight hours it's supposed to
wait Cigna teen breakfast break fast
yeah no I can do that that's not you
know fasting isn't that hard it's just
if you start at 4:00 in the afternoon
and then you know by the time you wake
up the next morning you've gone so long
me not really even hungry anymore yeah
and then you kind of find and it's just
that first night and then you're all
right I know a buddy of mine does it he
goes dude I still work out I don't do
anything goes I have this ridiculous
amount of energy and all this [ __ ] I was
just like I heard when you're fasting
you're not supposed to do that he's like
it's all [ __ ] it's all [ __ ] you
heard when you fast you're not supposed
to what exercise yeah like you're
supposed to [ __ ] be chilling no no
you can exercise you can definitely
especially anymore this second
non-doctor to tell me I could do that
yeah so I'm waiting for someone with at
least that has a lab coat Halloween
costume to tell me that I'll get down
D'Agostino he's a guy gets sad glad God
sad we have a guy that's been smarty is
asking you I'd be like I'm sorry does
your name rhyme whatever yeah that is
short for something like gadzooks one of
the great drummers of all time Steve
Gadd really mmm-hmm gadzooks is a great
name now if you name your kids get
Zuke's it's just it's just not fair to
Joe gadzooks is not a bad name it's kind
of cool
gadzooks remember that people would say
that gadzooks
I was like a comic book type thing like
when people are stunned
I'd say gadzooks I would say sting
I live in Zeus yeah Lebanon common male
Arabic name given a means Felicity I
know but the do they [ __ ] if your
last name is sad do you have to name
your kid GAD I just can't picture a part
of the world where your name [ __ ]
rhymes and you have to deal with that
every time oh god say yeah I get it it
rhymes
can I have my [ __ ] falafel I don't
want to talk to him huh you could do
your show he'll do show he's funny guy
you talked to about that I don't have
smart people on their podcast ever
you've never done it right why I make an
exception we did it at my place okay Syd
been that long yeah yeah yeah yeah or we
did it no we didn't do it at my house we
did it at the studio yeah yeah okay yeah
I like how you do it though I keep
telling comics I'm late look look what
Bill does he doesn't need anybody he
doesn't need anything
he's got a [ __ ] recorder and he just
rambles yeah that's great yeah that's
because of my childhood the way you just
said that what are you saying anybody
doesn't need anything he doesn't need
anything yeah that's where I went
and that was my protective place I went
mentally he doesn't start talking to
yourself no I was just like I [ __ ]
everybody I don't need anybody okay I
don't care which wasn't true I did care
right you did care but you just say I
don't care I don't give a [ __ ] that's a
pretty common thing amongst comics don't
you think no I think I'm unique oh no I
know I guess it is there's a few guys
that are doing that now like you though
like Theo von does his podcast very
similar to the way you do it he just
rambles you know daliyah does it very
similar just rambles but that's a great
it's gotta be a great way to develop
material like come on I try not to take
too much [ __ ] from there you know I
answer questions and [ __ ] I have like my
little [ __ ] tent poles I got to get
me through it but uh I man I don't know
like it just started I was a way to
promote my dates and I would just talk
hey what's going on I'd make a couple of
jokes oh I'm gonna be with the punchline
in San Francisco but boy it was only
like a minute long
two minutes long and then just got a
little longer and long I would tell some
stories I used to call in a service is
how I did it and it would record me on
the phone so I had my little flip phone
and I remember those yeah like at an
airport and talking on the phone it was
like a phone call yeah and I'd be making
fun of fat people and [ __ ] as they're
walking by how long were those then
those started to get to be 10 minutes 15
and then half hours to the point was you
know I noticed that was talking on a
cell phone like my head felt like it was
getting cooked and then you know then I
started like oh I need you know I'll
answer questions and I had a thing for a
while overrated underrated then I had a
segment is it racist but then somebody
said tosh point-o had something like
that so i'd get rid of that yeah just
kind of did that now I just I don't know
I just sit down sometimes I forget that
I'm [ __ ] talking to anybody all those
years of just being on the road just
talking to yourself in the car so do you
talk to yourself with the road on your
car yeah really I listen to music I
[ __ ] fantasize about being in the
band I listen to music when I listen to
a music like you pick any [ __ ] song
and I'll tell you who I am in the band
during it like I know you're an hour
Smith guy right so train kept a-rollin
I'm Joe Perry okay when he's [ __ ]
playing the guitar and then when Stephen
sings I'm Stephen do the whole fantasy
I'm just like jumping around like
[ __ ] I'm in Star Trek okay
and then when Joey Kraemer does the
[ __ ] the drum roll in the middle then
I'm Joey and yeah I just crush it it's
just a whole [ __ ] fantasy of me have
you ever met those guys I met Tommy
Hamilton joe perry did my podcast he's
great yeah
yes great guy down to earth yeah hanging
out with them you like forget just one
of the greatest guitarists of all time
yeah all the riffs syrota he's a regular
dude yeah Steven Tyler I met one time
yeah just all uh yeah but I I always
like you know just that that whole band
experience is it's very a lot like
stand-up where in the beginning you're
doing these impossible gigs mhm and you
get like this you know you know it's
it's like you against them and even like
cuz you came up as an open mic or the
band was kind of at the class of open my
kurz and you'd go up there and you know
if the crowd got the better of you you'd
like if you know if your buddy told that
person to shut the [ __ ] up or whatever I
just like that whole thing you know like
when I read that you know one of those
Guns and Roses books about how their
first gig was in Seattle and they had
this this van or something and it broke
down and they just kept going and they
just with thumbin and they just somehow
[ __ ] got there at the last second
they just did the gig you know I just
don't know so I just would think it
would be all like think it wasn't those
great feeling as a comedian to turn a
room around yeah but to actually being a
band and [ __ ] you know you did it
with somebody else you actually share it
with somebody as opposed to you know
[ __ ] doing it by yourself and then
going back to the super 8 you know I
love that you do those gigs where you
get together early with Dean Del Ray and
you guys play music and hear things dean
del rey can sing his [ __ ] ass off no
dude he's good yeah like he's really
good he has all the [ __ ] rock star
moves and [ __ ] like he's [ __ ] he's
legit yeah we had a great time the clips
he was showing you that was at the Forum
and then I'm singing a whole lot of
Rosie yeah I was like holy [ __ ] yeah
like that is he's got a [ __ ] voice on
yeah man and we didn't tune down a lot
of times like when you go see a band you
don't really notice but like they tune
down half a step or a full step and
sometimes you know people can get way
the [ __ ] down on certain songs but he
they still I saw Guns N'Roses recently
actually is give me some volume on yes
small
[Music]
that's Michael Devon on bass
- Andrew yeah
[ __ ] awesome cover yeah we did it
might be a little slow it's like you
guys are like you're you're a fun band
together but you got a legit
professional singer well that guy on
bass plays in Whitesnake that's Mike
Devon oh she's in Massachusetts guy no
he's a [ __ ] beast he's a piece for
some reason everybody looks like they
playing left-handed there I had a girl I
dated once I got in a car accident with
her some old man ran a red light and
slammed into us and I the car got
totaled sorry they're taking the car
away and I have a box of my cassettes in
the car and she sees the Whitesnake
cassette and she [ __ ] threw it away
she's like why you still listening to
this my bladder I'll let it throw it
awhile she must be beautiful she's
pretty hot she's older than me it's
night that's why 1988 chucked my [ __ ]
Whitesnake checked it out so sad and
because that's somebody sent me one that
somebody sent me a [ __ ] Whitesnake
cassette I got a Whitesnake cassette
sitting around here somewhere someone's
here dude I feel bad oh yeah
those first relationships this [ __ ] you
[ __ ] my [ __ ] you tolerate that's
amazing I know yeah I know but she was a
woman that was the thing I was still
kind of a boy and she was a woman you
know she was 25 she's on her own for
quite a while oh yeah I mean when I was
23 I dated a 30 year old mmm that was
not uh that was not the way to go David
I think they treated you like a toy yeah
and it was like you know she'd been
through a bunch of relationships so she
knew how to put up she knew how to post
up in the thing so I was just like she
was ready for you oh yeah yeah it was
fun she was cool and everything but it
was just like yeah then it didn't work
out yeah obviously yeah I felt like I
was a dog like I was a like I was a like
she got a dog you know like you know
chicks get a German Shepherd you know
yeah you were German Shepherd psycho
I was crazy back then to this house I
was still fighting so it was like I was
21 and she was uh graduated from college
grown woman had a job and a career at
CDs [ __ ] no cassette tapes anything
yeah I'd CDs in the cars in 88 did they
know they did cuz I remember a buddy of
mine in 88 a buddy of mine he had the
first one he had a Volkswagen Scirocco
that we thought was amazing right that
was like a sports car
yeah and he had this might have been 89
though 89 or 90 I came out but that's
kind of a blur back then so long ago but
he had like the they would like mount it
like you had almost like a disc man
it wasn't like in the dashboard and it
would just sit on like the little
console in the middle so another thing
if he went over a bump it would skip you
know and then they had like the big
suitcase they put in your trunk and that
way it holds like 18 [ __ ] CD CD
changers oh look at that yeah
is that it I tell you for whoa okay
their discs in 84
Wow well we were just out of high school
so he didn't have the money we thought
he was rich he had a Volkswagen Scirocco
well it's in his car in 1984 Wow you
know they had car phones back in like
the 60s that phones and cars oh yeah he
had to be at the presidential level yeah
super [ __ ] rich guy yeah yeah I'm
surprised you don't have a flip phone
surprise I'm going I would do it I I
mean I don't write but I like I played
my card games
spades and gin rummy and [ __ ] like that
whenever I'm in traffic now with the
Firebird something that's how I get
through traffic and I don't flip out as
I just [ __ ] stare at my phone
you don't listen to books on tape or
anything like that no I can't do that
you can't listen to books on tape I've
never tried
I just can't what would annoy me
listening to the person trying to make
it sound interesting
you know what the inflection with the
inflections and the voice and stuff no
you yeah
cousin hey I'm defensive oh this guy
thinks I'm a [ __ ]
that's just like and then in 1862
boo I'm just talking like that I just
forgot it just [ __ ] read it read it
like a sailor read it like a baby dude I
remember you know I have that reference
cuz I'm when I got busted for drunk
driving the the bailiff goes this is
what he said the giggle goes I pulled
the defendant over approximately blah
blah blah you know chasing through two
towns you know whatever and which I had
which was [ __ ] I anyways I had a
[ __ ] 83-14 Ranger and the bailiff
read the thing he said the arresting
officer asked the defendant where he's
coming from and he stated [ __ ] Boston
and it was just like that's not that's
what I said that's not the way I said it
I was [ __ ] wasted he said I was
trying to remember he said where'd you
come from I was like [ __ ] Boston
okay cuz [ __ ] Boston I want to get
out of the car I was like yeah I wasn't
a jerk but when the guy did the read
right he goes we asked him where he's
coming from he said [ __ ] Boston and
then it looked like a like you know oh
it's funny I stand there there's all
like these people who mugged people and
they were like laughing like this guy
that's got sticking it to the man I got
pulled over for drunk driving once when
I wasn't drunk I dropped my phone
dropped my phone on the highway reach
down and grab my phone and like you know
wiggle a little bit right and I wasn't
even reading my phone this is my phone
wasn't read my legs yeah and it fell on
I thought it was gonna get underneath my
accelerator and they pulled me over they
made me do all kinds of crazy [ __ ] and I
did it yeah I'm like I'm doing all of it
I'm like look at me I'm sober and then
they wanted me to take a breathalyzer
I'm like okay why do you want me to take
a breathalyzer like I don't know I don't
want to wanna trust your equipment he
just got done doing all the tests yeah
look I'm doing I'm on one foot I'm
[ __ ] pounds yeah what do you need me
to do I can I can do it set up some
cones like we do you want to know if I'm
drunk you know I'm not drunk so why you
want me to blow on your [ __ ] like
what's going on here and
they agree with me they'll let me go
right I said look I'm a big supporter of
police officers big supporter law
enforcement I donate I do
benefits whenever they come up and I'm
sober I'm sober you know the best ones
like most of my friends we all got
busted for drinking and driving the best
one was a buddy of mine they read his it
was like you know practically 4:00 in
the morning we noticed a maroon VW Fox
blowing its horn trying to pass on the
right we pulled the defendant over after
repeatedly asking the defendant to stay
in the car he got out of the car threw
his keys at my feet and repeatedly
stated locked me up I'm [ __ ] up this
is funny was my buddy was a good-looking
guy and the the judge was a was a woman
and when the guy read that you know
locked me up I'm [ __ ] up and he wasn't
the brightest guy and he just kind of
when he went like he put his head down
like that he was you know a little pound
puppy [ __ ] looking dude and she she
gave him like a lighter sentence and cuz
he was good-looking I think so yeah I
mean it all plays in sy ugly people are
complaining so much they won't take the
time to develop a [ __ ] personality
right some jobs do what the rest of us
have to do like I don't get mad at Brad
Pitt you know how that mean [ __ ] cuz
he's [ __ ] beautiful
I'm a [ __ ] bald redheaded male I know
where I am in the pecking order and some
of these [ __ ] people who are
complaining right now who are mad that
beautiful people get treated differently
I understand racially speaking but
you're not gonna do the beautiful thing
and then there's another thing that I
said well society tries to you know
they're the ones that [ __ ] didn't like
you know like I love one like there's a
supermodel like this is like an
impossible standard of beauty to try and
live up to yeah yeah yeah
that's why she's on the cover of a
magazine she's that level beautiful and
you're gonna try and sit there and tell
me that that was learned well here's the
thing that's only women because when you
see Jason Momoa
playing Aquaman you don't hear men say
that's an impossible standard of beauty
that we have to know I just make fun of
that [ __ ] stupid to hang on to how
much you can kick my ass that is the
dumbest you should be on a [ __ ]
cereal box
it's a trident for years they had a
problem like with Aquaman it's like he's
in the ocean
human beings are on earth like what do
we like I have to see that [ __ ] movie
what are they gonna be is it gonna be
like Japanese people like finning he's
be the same sharp he goes underwater is
that his skin like well the bumps what
is that is that a suit doesn't water get
in the gloves I think that have to be
all one piece right yeah you'd be
annoying is any worse than water in your
gloves well look it looks like he
catches him like a water catcher like
not just like water gets in the gloves
is like a funnel he looks like a
stripper at a bachelorette party she
pays money you got a good one
got dieted down for that yes he did he
got all the abs so he's bees better than
I am Oh his button it says this is the
fall everyone yeah this is when he's in
the Black Sea I don't know maybe wants
to [ __ ] gets cold
yeah did you see what's on going on in
the UK the UK is banned advertisements
that feature unobtainable bodies there's
a reason the way they eat fish and chips
over there that's gonna be most of
advertising
well they had these ads for summer
bodies you know you see a girl in a
bikini and they're now making it illegal
why can't you aspire to that like I look
at that Aquaman guy that makes me want
to go to the gym I don't be like you you
gonna fool in here look like you got to
make me feel better it's because the
people that complain who are the people
that complain the people that complain
to the people that don't want to work to
be that lady they don't want to work to
get that kind of a body and they want to
they just want to not see it they don't
want any didn't want to go to the subway
and see a body that they're never gonna
have yeah I saw I saw an actress
complaining one time because the studio
total that she needed to lose 15 pounds
and like you can't drop 15 to star in a
movie I mean what what carrot can they
specifically carrots some veggies in
your diet
what are they have to dangle in front of
you to go to the [ __ ] gym like the
rest of us like I literally like cuz I
would say all guys not to deal with
that's like yeah we do of course yes we
do I had to deal with that I have 19 20
pounds to forget about him it's just
having five lines in a [ __ ] movie if
I am north of 170 172 pounds the [ __ ]
tweets I get hey Billy booze bag hey
Billy [ __ ] tits hey fat freckles all of
this [ __ ] that I get like I know like
they sit there and they like it they're
like they're acting like like [ __ ]
preteens where everything is just
everything's about them and the whole
[ __ ] world gives us [ __ ] celebrities
but their [ __ ] political views is the
funniest thing ever it's like all you're
you're not you're not making anybody
change their mind politically I think I
need a [ __ ] speak up it's like no you
can't have the spotlight on you enough
that's all you're doing cuz all you're
doing with that [ __ ] is your first
of all you're alienating half the
[ __ ] people that are gonna go see
whatever the [ __ ] you're in and then
secondly you're just getting on the
radar of lunatics in white vans with two
seats that are looking up how to [ __ ]
build pipe bombs like that that's that's
the fallout it's like the jerk when he
goes average run-of-the-mill son of a
[ __ ] it already picks Steve Martin the
idea that a girl shouldn't be asked to
lose weight to look hot for a movie is
[ __ ] crazy because that's what you're
playing you're playing a hot woman and
there's our table and there's millions -
everybody's in shape I remember [ __ ]
see and I still a bit about this I saw
Ben Stiller in in in Meet the Fockers or
something there was a scene where he had
to have his shirt off in the pool he had
[ __ ] ABS you're in a comedy yeah cuz
that's because you were seeing the
influence of for the [ __ ] Internet
you know I mean it was just like you
know it gets in your head people just
[ __ ] trash and you like I already
knew I was unsightly but I didn't
realize how many things that people
didn't enjoy about till I got on the
internet I was like wow I never noticed
that about myself so yeah I don't have
look if some of you really has like a
[ __ ] eating disorder you know I feel
like [ __ ] obese I have sympathy for
those people but you're 15 pounds 20
pounds overweight I mean [ __ ] you
know eat drink some [ __ ] smoothies
these women that are playing these roles
have to understand first of all that
part of the reason why you got that role
is not just because of your acting
ability but also because you're pretty
you have a beautiful face you're born
with it
you didn't even work at it and then on
top of that you're supposed to be
playing a beautiful person in the movie
they would like you to not be fat well
there's also there's millions of dollars
at stake that could be lost so I always
feel like your job is even if you look
like me
is to show up on time knowing your lines
in the best possible shape you could get
yourself in that's that's the role
that's stupid
even if I'm just [ __ ] playing without
your Artie Lange what if you're already
Lange and you're supposed to play the
guy that smoking cigarettes and you're
the brother-in-law that's drunk all the
time then your job to look that what
about you jobs look that way yeah her
job is look at the hot woman that
everybody wants to [ __ ] they're telling
you you have to lose weight and you're a
beautiful woman it's because they want
to make you more attractive it's does
not like discrimination there's a reason
they want a better product I don't want
to make money yeah they want to try the
product and I'll tell you nothing to
like really but those both male and
female like those beautiful people at
that level it's like they're [ __ ]
aliens like I I've done a couple of
movies I did a movie one time and I
remember it was a scene we were in a car
and the star of the movie was holding on
to the steering wheel and I was like
like I never thought this ever about a
woman I was like her forearms are
gorgeous I was looking at like I was
like those forearms are perfect but I
didn't make me when I went to Stockholm
Sweden how beautiful the people with it
I was running down the street pointed
guys with my wife Gonia look at that guy
look at that that [ __ ] guy like he's
like an accountant walking down the
street like does he know if you [ __ ]
came over here he'd be starring in
movies and that's not all a Sweden by
the way that's like just when you're in
Stockholm that's like their Manhattan so
all the beautiful [ __ ] people but I
mean I went into a couple I went to this
maggot plate one and bought like a
magazine and something like that when I
was over there and the woman behind the
counter was like a [ __ ] 11 here but
she was working at a magazine stand so
that was her energy okay how you do I'm
working in a magazine and my dream
hasn't come true yet you just look at
him like you you could sign with who is
that big modern agents yeah like that
all like Cyndi cross
while them are worth back in the day the
Vikings its Viking blood they the
best-looking people they went over there
and raped and pillaged and all that good
DNA is left there they caught the best
women they kept them alive kill
everybody else I always had what
happened oh yeah I don't know what
happened Vikings like that's why they're
so big beautiful
oh yeah no this super trophy that's one
of the funniest things ever when you go
over to like the what do they call this
the Nordic you see and then Scandinavia
swith in the Nordic countries always
have to remind myself at that like you
go over there was the funniest [ __ ]
[ __ ] cuz they're so goddamn tall there
would be kids almost my height whose
voices hadn't changed yet and they had
the mentality of like an 11 year old man
like except they were speaking that I
said hi to change it how did what are
they talking boy said and change it and
I was just sitting there laughing my ass
off go this is like [ __ ] yeah they
like everybody was like like six-three
six-four six-five like rail-thin with
their [ __ ] european pants i'm
actually going over there coming that's
i'm stockholm next year but i'm going
over europe i got that i got a run a 10
10 days over there yeah i saw you're
doing a european tour when you do that
doing three legs of it three legs so you
do three separate trips of ten days Wow
yeah just cuz I you'll bring the family
do just go solo I'm gonna bring the
family on one of them and then the other
ones I'm only gone for a little over a
week which is a really long time when
you have a kid and it's not something
that I look forward to doing now but
it's something that it's also gives my
kid a great life so right how I
justified so then I also I had to move
some [ __ ] around to work less in other
areas but uhm that's a good balance I'm
glad you approached it that way you know
I have friends that don't they do you
know they're on the road all the time
and they have kids and you know their
idea is that this is what I got to do to
make a living right make sure I guess so
but you know I gave you 30 days in a row
it's kind of crazy I put my kid down for
a nap and like I'll be downstairs for
like 20 minutes I look at my wife I'm
like dude I miss her it's just it's so
quiet she's hilarious she's hilarious so
it's just like you know yeah and she's a
humble
believable sense of humor and yeah and
actually love it yeah yeah and I always
wanted to be and I just was afraid of
commitment and all that [ __ ] so I waited
all right I waited too long I did wait
too long so it was just why I'm gonna
take a [ __ ] sauna with you at the end
of this yeah we'll take a sauna now yeah
and I want to learn off and and you know
G would be really be great if there was
a company out there that could somehow
let me know I get a Sun in my house
well sauna people out there I was
working with if you get a white snake
take I can get a [ __ ] get a sauna
sauna companies contact both of us okay
because I was in contact with a guy to
do something in my [ __ ] house and
this [ __ ] dropped the ball and is not
returning emails anymore hmm so I need a
new sauna company to call me a free
advertising where's the [ __ ] sauna
sauna guy get back to us no he gets
[ __ ] in two weeks should we get back
to him again I twice got back to this
guy like trying to get the [ __ ] sauna
installed in the house I love that glass
stuff like that they're like comedians
like they don't want a real job
contractors oh yeah no the gate guy
that's on a guy that this guy that guy
they all got their little [ __ ] and then
the handyman guys well I grew up with
those guys because I my dad was an
architect so I did construction from the
time I was in high school all throughout
the summer I was always doing side jobs
always had jobs on construction sites as
a laborer carpenters assistants I was
always around those guys I tried to do
that I lasted eight days I just with my
[ __ ] fair skin we were doing roofing
in July and it was just I just remember
my job was I was putting in the
scaffolding going around you know when
you [ __ ] drill the hole then you put
the triangle thing and then you [ __ ]
put the bolt on yeah Irish guy kept
going Billy you must look quicker you
much more quickly isn't he kept saying
to me and I finally stuck my head out
the side of the house I was like dude
I've done this for three days if you
want me to [ __ ] go quicker you know
when we would like literally three
stories up and he finally shut the [ __ ]
up he must be a non-union guy oh yeah
dude I remember there was a [ __ ] guy
on the site I swear to god he were the
same [ __ ] jeans every day with like
no underwear right I had a [ __ ] giant
[ __ ] hole right here on his thigh
so I'm in [ __ ] working in the house
and I just remember he stepped over
something with this left leg and the
whole [ __ ] hole moved right just like
flashed his [ __ ] junk I was just like
and I didn't know how to stand up to
people and plus else you know I was a
new guy on the thing and I just was
wanted to be like buddy how about you
put on some [ __ ] boxers or something
so I don't get a look at your [ __ ]
gym first of all he's walking around
like a goddamn nail gun not like boxers
could stop that but any extra layer of
clothing that you could have this guy's
literally like his [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
like an owl looking out of a tree and
it's burned into my head is dead I could
pick his junk out of a lineup that was
the first time I ever encountered
alcoholics I didn't really know about
alcoholics so I started working on job
sites I realized there was guys that
just had a drink they drink at lunch
they were just drinking all the time
they were always trying to quit I
remember one guy is like I'm quit and
I'm done
and I remember thinking that's good you
can't you [ __ ] together you know 15 it's
like oh that's awesome yeah
two weeks later [ __ ] can of beer on
the job I was like oh I just remember I
could yeah I couldn't eat enough I
wasn't always hungry I was I packed two
sandwiches three sandwiches and he did
use butter like like you were on - yeah
that's what people used to do no those
were like like those guys I mean I I
would come home like I was like I went
to football practice it was just it's
just yeah I I if I stuck around for
another month I could have got in
construction worker shape I was but I
just sucked at it I just didn't have it
and that was one of the things how I was
able to figure out what I was good at
was one of my best attributes is I knew
when I sucked at something like take
playing drums that I wanted to be in a
band and I think I just went to too many
music stores and I see some
seven-year-old kid and just him starting
to play or picking up a guitar I just
knew it I was just like I don't have
that I don't have that gift you know
even if I play better than I just the
ideas that they were already coming up
with I'm speaking of what you I should
have called you the other day I saw Dave
Navarro does this thing with this band
Royal machines it's like this they just
do this Christmas show every year
and I went with Ben Bailey the other
night at the El Rey do what a [ __ ]
show these guys put on like Sebastian
Bach came out saying highway to hell
[ __ ] murder dude Juliette Lewis you
know from [ __ ] American I wanted what
the [ __ ] was that one with all the all
the edits the serial killer movie with
Woody Harrelson yeah what the [ __ ] was
that after going Natural Born Killers
although you know all of those [ __ ]
move dude you know some people like I'm
a comedian who happens to play drums
dude she's a [ __ ] rock star who
happens to act really dude oh my god
really oh my god mushy was so ridiculous
I was just laughing how [ __ ] amazing
she was she's saying like van Halen
ain't talking about love and then she
sang dirty deeds
it was all just in the wheelhouse of
[ __ ] that I listen to and I'd want to
say she did one more and then in the end
she did like a [ __ ] forward
somersault into the [ __ ] crowd whoa
it was just [ __ ] is there video this
um I don't know I was I you know they
the band was so [ __ ] good and then
the drummer's they had was josh freese
chad smith and brad wilk
like so you know if you're in the drums
that's just racist [ __ ] play with
everybody ever literally everybody brad
wilk was in Rage Against the Machine and
and Chet Smith is in the Chili Peppers
and those guys were just [ __ ]
destroying and who they had Steve
Stevens for Billy Idol's band was out
there all these [ __ ] guys it's just
like wow yeah if you get a chance they
were kind of talking like it was the
last year they were gonna do it I hope
it isn't but mark McGrath also was there
who was [ __ ] hilarious he's sort of
like the like you know well you know he
sings the songs great but he's also like
sort of the MC slash comedian he's a
really really naturally like funny guy
like he I was there with another
comedian he was cracking us up he went
on to be like an entertainment reporter
right yeah well the thing about him is
he's like he was over I feel like he was
always like self-deprecating yeah like
he was writing hit songs like who the
[ __ ] can do that and he nicknamed an
album like 1459 like making fun like my
50
minutes are almost up like he was like
roasting himself while he was just
writing one hit after another after
another and uh I've gotten to meet him a
couple times he's like one of the
[ __ ] great people that I've met in
this business I've heard nice things
yeah dude and he's a [ __ ] riot he's a
funny yeah so if you get it you guys
like that you go why don't you just do
stand-up why do you want to work these
[ __ ] gigs working for entertainment
television pretending you give a [ __ ]
about some stupid sitcom well because
how much of a chance would people give
him cuz like tell your the Sugar Ray guy
me probably got enough [ __ ] you know
trying like he's just one of those
really like John the bridge that was
funny [ __ ] now Wow so there's Navarro
that's I think that's brad wilk on drums
whatever but he was making fun of
himself before he came out there cuz I
forget who's following he's going like I
know I know now you got to listen to the
douche from sugar so just totally make
fun of his then he goes up and he
[ __ ] murders it Wow so it's just kind
of like like he just reminded me of like
like a comedian or whatever so did you
get to hang out with Juliette Lewis um
no I I have before she's cool as [ __ ] I
want to meet her oh she's cool we've
gone back and forth online together I
was trying to get her on the podcast a
few years ago and I drop a ball oh
alright I was always worried that people
like that would worry that I just want
to harp on Scientology because she's you
know she's like a crazy Scientologist no
I grew up Catholic but what the [ __ ]
they did and still doing mm-hmm yeah no
listen I hear you but she I think she's
still active they get sensitive about
that [ __ ] I always thinking of going
back to church really yeah just in my
own way how you gonna do it I'm gonna go
but I'm not gonna listen to anything you
know I'll stand up and sit down you
gonna get mad if they use certain
inflections no but I'm just gonna kind
of go there it's just a place I don't
know I
went last year with my mother-in-law
because she goes every week and when I
went for Christmas Mass and they had
like this New Orleans band and it was I
was like dude if they had this every
[ __ ] week cuz the band sounded great
I would go but like I did it just sort
of reminded me of like I used to be a
better person I was associated you know
I used to go every [ __ ] week
you think you're jaded from not going to
church or just I think you jaded just
from knowing too much
yeah and just you know no it's just
certain things you just get out of
control you know what it is when you
become an adult you have to be your own
parent which is weird like hey bill it's
time to go to bed hey Bill lay off the
booze and just you know just certain
things just kind of get out of whack you
know almost like the mixer your life you
know something's up too high or too low
and I just felt like going there
reminded me you know sex a nice reminder
for the week like hey you know how could
you not be a [ __ ] for the next couple of
days that's what I get out of it I don't
get like you know this guy walked on
water and you know this is the right
thing you know if you believe this you
gotta go to heaven and if you know if
somebody believes something else they're
going to hell like all of that stuff is
just silly that's the way you put is a
good way of putting it that you have to
be your own parent when you become an
adult that's a great way of putting it
because one of the things you get from
whether it's God or any kind of
spirituality is you get this idea that
something's bigger than you
something's higher than you there's a
higher purpose and you think about that
instead of being selfish and just
thinking about that's what it is
you can get like you know being a comic
not selling tickets is one of the most
humbling things ever and then once you
start selling tickets you you know you
can kind of he can kind of float away a
little bit and just like you know like
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] that you had to
go through you know finding a flight you
can afford and how am I going do cat
haired car they're gonna pull up in to
take them to the comedy condo that was
always cat hair right and then all of
that goes away and then you know you
just have this free time right and like
what are you gonna do with it in this
free time in this privilege that you
have and you can really go Roman Empire
with it
and [ __ ] eat and drink and smoke and
be a you know and just be a jerk or you
can you know you can I don't still be
who the photo be as much as who you were
or whatever are trying to help somebody
out I just that's what it makes me think
of when when I went like I was cuz I got
so caught up in like this is [ __ ]
that never happened they made that up
this is just people right in this book
and I went totally the other way Sam
coming in the middle like there's a
reason why people do this beyond trying
to control people and make money and
power and all that there is there is
something to it so there's a benefit for
the people that yes yeah yes so that's
kind of what I think I was going there
it's humbling it's kind of like when I
left LA never spoken to be good and then
I would start going back and I felt it
pulling me back like hey you know this
isn't that bad I'm like [ __ ] I kind of
like it so I went back to the church
with my mother-in-law and I was sitting
there going like there's an aspect of
this that I liked I like the sense of
community yes you know I didn't mind the
little pep talk that the guy gives or
whatever it would be nice if I didn't
didn't think if I wasn't suspicious of
them
the problem with Church is the problem
with anybody that gets in any sort of a
position of power it's easy to abuse it
so to have a guy who's a pastor that's
not a creep and that really cares and is
really a good person and really wants to
care about the community and really
write wants everybody to do better and
get better with life but isn't trying to
buy a [ __ ] Rolls Royce like Joel
Olsteen and live in a giant mansion it's
like it always megachurch and always
goes it always goes south it's
absolutely love about Joel Osteen is
he's an arena act yeah yes as a preacher
he's he bought the old place the old
arena where the the Houston Rockets
asked to play he bought it
yeah that's how much money that guy has
and then he fills it up yeah well that
was when the hurricane came people
criticized him because he didn't open up
his doors to all the folks who were
displaced from their home I was teasing
them about that it's like you saw that
electric blue carpet he put on anything
what yo you [ __ ] guys getting it all
wet
no he does he has his sick ass look at
that place oh maybe it's the curtain
that I thought yeah I mean look at that
[ __ ] place
holy [ __ ] yeah that looks like a Dice
Clay special and all those people are
throwing down all those people are
paying to be there that guy is making I
want there's somebody out there scalping
tickets I got two by the altar there's
two ways of looking at it right one is
these getting all those people together
and there's a sense of community amongst
all of them and two is that guys making
a fuckload of money and he's got so much
power you know you and all those people
just at your but doesn't mean you
necessarily a bad that doesn't
necessarily mean he's like what what can
you do with it which is getting the
reason why I'm thinking uh you know
stopping in every once in a while I find
a good spot like they were doing that
rock and roll Church thing for a while
there was a I remember one of my friends
was a producer his assistant was she was
lost she I think she spiritually or she
was lost in a lot of ways but she was
doing this what's going on Jamie Oh what
$4,950 yeah do you want to go what the
[ __ ] yeah we could do that for thousands
four hundred bucks
no no no four thousand nine hundred
fifty dollars per ticket for to take
five thousand where resection for Rodi
Rodi dude four grand and let that guy
[ __ ] that's not even at this I catch
the handkerchief when he's done [ __ ]
preaching how much I get for up bro to
or not available not available so now
he's a resell tickets do you know what
it is man they got [ __ ] season passes
people probably buy season passes to
Holsteins to this tour this was for this
Florida stop well I saw there was a
place that I was at that he was coming
to I'm one of them one of the big spots
I was at he does these arena tours and
he does Vegas to he does the [ __ ]
t-mobile arena in Vegas I want to see
the show up there his eyes open and a
smile and [ __ ] it's crazy it's a lot of
money that guys make I used to say he's
so full of [ __ ] he can't look at the
crowd that's why his eyes are like
they're still here how they still
believe in this [ __ ]
and when you're lying I contact is the
toughest [ __ ] thing ever but he's
making people feel good knees maybe he's
in show business I want to see the show
though he's in the God show biz you have
this you have to respect an arena act I
think I think there's something to that
yeah there's something right it's uh
this girl that I was talking about she
was real lost and I think she was Jewish
at four maybe she converted to Judaism
later but anyway for one point time she
was going to this rock-and-roll church
she was like she was a sweet kid she was
like you should go you would really like
it I'm like I guarantee I wouldn't like
it I'm like with some young hip guy
probably sing songs probably tries to
[ __ ] women like get out of here with
that right like a yoga class it's like
David Koresh right that's how Waco got
started how did he get started get
started with one guy with a guitar and
he brought that message of Jesus and he
had some really profound things to say
and people really it really helped them
feel better resonated with them then you
start banging people's wives and that's
what happens yeah well those rock and
roll alternative churches there's a few
they like the Justin Bieber guy you know
the guy that Justin Bieber has he's the
one who told Justin to get off the road
laughter Oh Justin come back home to
Jesus like he's gets these guys to do
that wait you get a basketball player I
stopped playing basketball to not uh
play wait no no no no no that guy's not
doing the road anymore
girl's back and forth you know took a
little time off yes to her cancel his
tour because the the preacher told them
it's well maybe he's right though let's
be honest first of all Bieber probably
has a [ __ ] billion dollars in the
bank and maybe he was frayed around the
edges as losing his [ __ ] marbles the
kids 21 years old he's about as famous
as a human being could possibly be only
21
there's the preacher what the [ __ ]
dick root priest hold up what's what's
going on with his [ __ ] shorts bro
no no no no no no any guy who's showing
dick root you know I mean like the base
of your [ __ ] you're pulling your shorts
down to base your [ __ ] like that you're
doing that because you're trying to get
laid
stop pull your [ __ ] shorts up to a
normal height those things should be 5
inches higher I know what you're doing
your your [ __ ] is slapping against your
thing you probably don't even have
underwear on you [ __ ] creep Jesus
does not want you dressing like that no
look at him he's got abs big old
handsome guy he probably dicks chicks
down for the Lord right dicks dicks them
down for Jesus
big ol handsome charismatic guy dick it
him down for Jesus apparently he's a
very good hanging with Oprah so you know
he's legit they're all in the same
business
so enjoy you're all enjoy hey maybe he's
good at it you know maybe he's got
something maybe helps people I'm
suspicious I'm suspicious because of his
shorts just that alone they should be on
the wall all over his church this is me
at my worst well the worst thing you do
it as an adult is to go out and try and
find parents again yeah that's the
quickest way to end up in the trunk of
somebody's [ __ ] car find someone to
take care of you yeah well you see if
you hide it see that your parents didn't
pay attention to you or overly coddled
you I think then you go out and you
start looking for a mom and a dad a mom
and a dad and a mom and a dad you just
give away all this [ __ ] power power
weight as someone who shows dick root
when they pull their shorts down to the
base of their [ __ ] like that like as far
as you can legally get your shorts down
without showing your dick so I was the
pubes that trimmed I don't think it's
okay it's alright that's interesting
right he's got it he's got it
damned it'll be a problem cuz gonna get
chaos down there and he pulled it out
you could see the chaos like basically
that's that's there's a lot of pubes
that you could see right there you could
see a lot of pubes but if you did it
would be a real issue isn't that
interesting the same exact area is okay
if you're only seeing skin but if you
saw pubes right there you'd be like hey
man what in the [ __ ] what are you doing
that is so not acceptable
in public that like that is that's
almost like the male version of a thong
like a guy could can't wear a thong but
it's worse but it's funny though least
if you have a thong on you just a freak
alright I'm a freak
I gotta be honest a naked guy always
funny
it's pretty funny Thank You Johnny it
depends depends on the special guy well
if you're alone and somebody jumped out
of a bush I mean that's [ __ ] that's
not a funny naked guy he went back in
the day when streaking that's right when
a guy would jump out and run across a
football field it was the funniest it
was just the funniest [ __ ] thing
tackle the guy now he's had it they
always had a silly hat and they would
just start [ __ ] running across and
would always get me the feet I would I
would can sup when I'd see them tackling
because I would think about his dick his
raw dicks smashing into hot dirt I saw a
guy I saw a guy when I was at a Boston
University Terriers game they don't even
play soccer anymore Nickerson Field and
my fault
my godfather took me to the game and we
were sitting in this [ __ ] alley it
was a bandana on and he was streaking
across the field and we were [ __ ]
crying laughing he and security was
chasing him really fast yeah they had a
bandana in like these [ __ ] like you
know adidas Dragons you knows way back
in the day right [ __ ] it ran across and
he tried to jump over this [ __ ]
concrete thing and he didn't land with
his junk it was his inner thigh on the
other one I was just like he got over
and he and as far as I know he got away
but I mean dude it was just um it wasn't
even like it wasn't nice concrete it was
that rough unfinished [ __ ] and he tried
to hurtle it and he got he got his junk
he got everything over and it was that
other let other leg nice [ __ ]
rasberry it's amazing how vulnerable you
dick his dick and balls just just a
simple simple trip with no pants on and
slam down on your dick he isn't horrible
I would think there'd be some sort of
junk ribcage to try to try and protect
it but it just a turtle shell no no it's
just [ __ ] just out there just out
there yeah it's it's a terrible design
and that's why the function is I mean it
has to go in you know in case you didn't
notice you haven't been using your dick
you know what it's for it so it's
something that someone has got
something's got to be vulnerable
you know like a star because you're the
temperature that's what it's for
temperature your body heats up too much
it kills your sperm so if your balls
were internal and you were running
around exercising you would cook all
your sperm so their balls are hanging
low on the outside well well why can't
it go like in and out like one of those
electric antennas maybe in the future
well yeah yeah people keep evolving you
find a way to suck it up into your body
that was the thing that we'd always hear
about weight Chiru guys we cheer ooh is
a very particular hardstyle karate and
guys would literally get kicked in the
balls they would kick each other in the
balls and the idea was that and under
some dubious instructors the idea was
that these guys could actually suck
their testicles up into their body like
they would train to pull their testicles
up into their body and one day I talked
to a doctor and he's like that's not
possible no it is like no but they think
they can but there's some guys can
develop the ability to take a shot to
the nuts like there's been studies done
on it there was one of those sports
science shows where these guys they
measured like the amount of force that
the guys throwing at this guy's dick
when he punched him in the dick and they
I stand in it like this just [ __ ]
straight-up punt him right in the balls
and he can take I said in effect his dad
it's definitely not good there's a trick
to it there's certainly a trick the
trick would be that even though you are
definitely making contact with the balls
really the most of the force is in the
taint in the back of the ass because as
you know you're kicking somebody right
your foot is extends past where your
shin is right your shin is here your
foot is here so if your foot is slamming
into the guy's ass and taint it's really
not really thought about this I have and
I've been kicked in the balls at least a
hundred times hard by grown men who know
how to kick by black belts I've been
kicked in the balls so many times
because when you're sparring you get
kicked in the balls all the time I mean
all the time
you probably just get used to the pace I
thought before I had kids I thought I
bite my [ __ ] balls are probably
totally useless like I'm shooting blanks
for sure I just thought of all the times
been slammed into the balls I'm here
I mean I've had I've worn every [ __ ]
cup there is especially back when I was
competing they didn't like now they have
some pretty sophisticated cups with like
diamond MMA as this cup that's got a
compression short and it sucks down into
you and it's really hard rubber on the
outside and you can actually take a good
shot to the balls and it's not gonna
kill you but back when I was doing he
would get those jocks would just be a
cup that fits in a jockstrap and you
pull them up and then eventually they
made some for martial arts where it just
curved under a little bit more and the
cup went back to your taint and the the
downside of that was it was there was a
lot of a abrasiveness when you were
throwing kicks it was like rub against
your your inner thigh and there's no
compression shorts back then either
but I absolutely been I could [ __ ]
bet everything I have I've been kicked
in the balls a hundred times no question
about it they should take like [ __ ]
you know like they do like a mold they
should do a mold of your junk custom
they should know me that group uses like
a mold of like all the rockstars dicks
right yeah
seem like a fleshlight for porn stars
yeah that so they would like that's
secure yeah I just yeah I get I get
weirded out by yeah I get weirded out by
that [ __ ] flashlights yeah like what's
this the nonhuman element in that gay
you want to [ __ ] this thing that isn't
alive there's just something like you
know yeah that's just [ __ ] this is my
[ __ ] it's a rubber version of my
[ __ ]
oh yeah oh [ __ ] I always yeah back in
the day when he had wanted to get porn
he had to go into his store I just
thought that stuff always it just seemed
serial killer like body part type
humanizing yeah it's very effective
though the fleshlight was a sponsor for
a while
when I remember the days yeah those
things were great I know I'd stopped
using them though even though like I was
trying to try it I had to try it after a
while he did it feel listeners oh yeah
that's it only for the listeners it's
very effective
okay so you know about this what's that
it's called a pachinko what oh Jesus
Christ
I mean you it's a hobby one how do you
not like become like how does that not
do brain damage - [ __ ] that oh Jesus
that's so disgusting can you think it's
bad getting caught jerking off can you
imagine it if you swam in this foot
India's [ __ ] first of all it looks
real enough that you [ __ ] killed
somebody now you [ __ ] oh my god you
can [ __ ] a whole leg that is crazy how
realistic that looks it looks like she's
hanging from the ceiling dude this even
has like the skin of her heel looks like
it's kind of mushy a little bit right
like it's moving around because I want
this site might get a little weird
adjust as you can build your own
mannequin here okay let's just get the
[ __ ] out yeah we are we're like that
what are you doing I'm in synthetics
that's what that's called synthetics
parachutes and stuff like that something
something like that what is it
everyone on our [ __ ] elbow you do
here's my business card
[Laughter]
I don't know that's when like I think
you buy that and a few weeks later you
buy a giant freezer just think you're
going down that road man yeah which I
honestly think like there's so many
people that had tendencies that never
when you're just living in log cabins
and [ __ ] like you just never were able
to explore and I feel like the same way
you know I can watch all these people
building cars and stuff or you can tap
into some dark [ __ ] about yourself and
you know that thing opens the coffin lid
and sits up and then that's in your
[ __ ] personality now it's it's a very
it's a very no yeah I try to stay away
from [ __ ] like that well especially if
your kid that's been abused I think
that's the real trigger real triggers
kids that get abused they get abused
young and then they develop this anger
this hatred and
and as they get older then they find
these weird outlets then they pursue
them yeah yeah yeah yeah I can attest to
a lot of it basically describe my
[ __ ] life
so anyways we're gonna [ __ ] let's go
get in the sauna let's do it we'll wrap
this up ladies and gentlemen Jesus
Christ now you're looking at your
[ __ ] foot when I'm in there yes
please show me something else yeah
prigioni of Comedy benefit February 19th
an amazing line-up for the greatest live
comic I ever [ __ ] saw big Jay oakerson
Chris read cipher sounds Gary Gulman Jim
Gaffigan Michelle wolf rich Voss and
other people that will I'll try to talk
Joe into flying out there for it in the
sauna when he gets [ __ ] down yourself
hell of a Sheldon
one of these years one of these years
we've got to get you out there I'll be
happy to oh and f is for family season 3
season 3 streaming now on netflix
damn whoo alright thanks for bank you
Joe bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]